so we got the numbers out of georgia for
the turnout in the gop primary and it is
almost double the numbers from the
previous midterm in 2018 almost double
and i saw that i thought to myself how
do you go from 600 000 republican voters
to 1.1 million
well there's a couple ways you can do it
you can destroy the economy you can send
62 billion dollars to an eastern
european war you can
pull security off the southern border
and have a bunch of illegal immigrants
flood the country
you can then put many of those younger
illegal immigrants on planes and fly
them around the country in the cover of
knight much to the chagrin of many
republicans those are all
those are ways you can do it but
something else happens when you do that
not only do you rile up republicans to
come out and vote nearly double the
numbers you convince a bunch of
democrats to switch parties and that's
what it looks like is happening there is
from the ajc.com
the atlanta general constitution i
believe it is
seven percent swing so about seven
percent of democrats between seven and
ten percent
switched from democrat to republican in
this primary now that's massive but that
doesn't account for the entirety of all
of the republicans coming out to vote
this is what i've been saying it's not
going to be a red wave if these numbers
hold if this is the trend we're seeing
it's not even going to be a red tsunami
it is going to be a red great flood and
the democrats will need to prepare their
ark now because they're going to get
wiped out of federal federal government
and possibly even state government
stacey abrams is saying she's going to
be the governor
if seven to ten percent of democrats
have flipped parties you're not winning
anything so these are these are huge
numbers but there's a lot that's going
to happen between now and then so we
will see we got a bunch of other news as
well beta o'rourke is just a
nasty guy he stood up at a press
conference for this tragedy in texas and
starts yelling some political nonsense
about the governor and parents were
booing him like dude
that's inappropriate so we'll talk about
that plus we got joe biden
he said something about deers wearing
kevlar again and everyone's just face
palming like dude come on you know so we
got to talk about that we got george
soros saying that the war in europe with
ukraine could be the end of civilization
certainly we have a lot of things to
talk about aoc says she wants to get rid
of her tesla because elon musk had she
was hitting on him
walmart's apologizing for selling
juneteenth ice cream
oh man there's a lot going on joining us
to talk about all this we got a couple
people but we have will wit
introduce yourself good sir i'm will
witt live in los angeles california
worked for prageru for about the last
five years 25 years old 160 pounds
anything else what's your sign uh i
think virgo virgo you're not sure okay
yeah i don't wear crystals and those
kind of things okay yeah well there you
go oh what you what do you do like
what's your official role yeah so
basically a prageru i'm a political
commentator i create a lot of the man on
the street videos you guys have ever
seen for prageru uh national bestselling
author of how to win friends and
influence enemies done a couple short
documentaries uh podcasting all sorts of
different hats that i've done so
marketing social media
anything really to to help the
conservative movement and to help truth
with prageru that's that's what i do
cool we also have ava yes yes i'm uh
first and foremost will's fiance
congratulations thank you thank you um
i'm i'm a lawyer i'm from the
netherlands and i write i'm a political
commentator right over there but i i
mean everything's international nowadays
so i talk a lot about well basically
everything
um yeah i actually only got your first
name that's why i only said your first
name yeah that's right i can say it yeah
yeah what is it it's flared in your book
flirting yeah yeah i mean you can say
flarding or brook that's how that's how
tucker carlson said it oh yeah what does
it mean
it basically flowered is a is well
blue itself means it means pants but not
in this context flowering is a city in
the south of the netherlands and uh book
is sort of a swampy area near that city
so okay there you go swampy area cool
that's my last name you would wear pants
in if you were in the area like so
you'll get all those on your leg or
something uh well in this in this
context it has nothing to do with pants
but
in and of itself is also pants so yeah
it's wild
it's got kind of a breathy sound to it
that language
yeah yeah yeah well wait til you're here
are g's they're not so brilliant give me
one yeah yeah like that
okay
yeah what's up everybody ian crossland
happy to be here let's keep let's roll
this over to lydia yeah what do you
think thanks ian i'm here in the corner
i'm excited to have my lady as always
this was an unexpected surprise and i'm
delighted to have some international
conversation tonight before we get
started my friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your biotrust ageless multi-collagen to
keep your skin joint hair and nails
looking young and supple and healthy if
you go to biotrust uh if you go to
strongerbonesandlife.com to pick up your
biotrust college and you'll get 51 off
and for me i was just skating earlier
today so i definitely take this stuff
seriously because you know i'm 36 i'm
getting old and everybody's everybody's
always commenting how i shouldn't be
skating because i'm too old to do it
well i take my ageless multi-collagen so
i'm fine i actually feel fantastic i
don't know if it's this or anything else
but i don't feel any different from what
i've been skating since i was 19 until
today some people i talked to who have
been skating since uh same same time as
me are just like old and fat and they're
like i can't skate anymore and i'm like
dude you need to get healthy anyway go
to stronger bones in life.com and you'll
get a 60 day money back guarantee the
healthy aging support of collagen in
ideal forms five key types of collagen
you need from four different sources
essential to optimally support an array
of full body benefits for every order
today we will donate biotrust will
donate a nutritious meal to a hungry
child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbst
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth and other collagen supplements
there's no clumping unlike other
supplements as well you'll get free
shipping with every order free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust's team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order again
strongerbonesandlife.com
also head over to timcast.com if you'd
like to support us directly there's
going to be a members only show going up
around 11 or so p.m tonight we do this
monday through thursday as a member
you'll get access to those exclusive
segments you'll also be supporting our
journalists and
our engineers because check this out on
the home page right now we have created
this new feature where the live player
shows it says watch live now there's a
red flashing light and it has the
youtube player and the chat however
because the chat is subscriber only you
have to be logged in i'm not sure you
can actually use the chat but you can
watch it
we are still developing the
infrastructure and still building it out
with your support we're gonna do a whole
lot of really really cool things we have
some uh other big announcements coming
really really soon i keep teasing this
because i think it's gonna be happening
any day now but
we are doing a lot on the infrastructure
side to get away from big tech in
silicon valley to make ourselves more
resistant to censorship so with your
support at timcast.com we'll do that
don't forget smash that like button
right now subscribe to this channel
share the show wherever you can if every
single person watching right now shared
this we would be bigger than the
corporate press overnight
now let's get into that first big story
i'm going to start with this tweet from
ryan james gardusky
he says georgia gop primary turnout by
year in 2018 608 380. in 2022 1 million
109
506. that is
almost double so as i mentioned in the
intro to this show
for those that didn't see it
there's a lot of a lot of ways you can
accomplish that you know i was saying
like destroying the economy is one of
those ways i think that certainly
shocked a bunch of people five dollar a
gallon gasoline is gonna get a lot of
people to the polls but i also think
it's going to get a lot of democrats to
switch and that's a contributing factor
check this out from the atlanta journal
constitution data shows thousands of
democrats voting in gop primary they say
seven percent of georgia voters who cast
a gop ballot previously polled a
democratic ballot two years ago
if that's true and you actually go down
and look at the democrat numbers it
looks like democrats dropped by about
seven percent republicans jumped by
about seven percent so it looks like
democrats may have dropped anywhere from
seven to uh ten percent republicans jump
seven percent well they're trying to say
that that's some ploy by the democrats
to make it get the candidates that they
want and all that kind of stuff i mean
that's nonsense it's nonsense the thing
that really matters about this that
you know i live in los angeles
california and people are going to be
liberal there until the world ends it's
going to be an apocalyptic leftist
nightmare forever and so what i think is
important is that
it's about the children i think that
this is the most about the schools
what's happening with the transgender
movement and what's happening with our
education system i think we saw what
happened in virginia and i think that if
we continue on the path as conservatives
hammering on education then we're going
to be able to continue to switch voters
you switch independent voters you switch
democrat voters over to republican and
if you have republicans who come out and
say listen my number one priority is
education my number one priority is your
kids because the left thinks that the
schools own your kids the parents
shouldn't have a say in your kids lives
if conservatives and republicans keep
pushing on that then
you will win you will switch people over
i think it was might have been james
lindsay who said this that the democrats
are turning parents into a voting block
yeah that's great yeah i mean i'm
speaking at all these rallies all these
different things especially again in
california you know whether they're
coveted rallies or education rallies and
i've said this a thousand times before
this is a revolution of normal people
like these people who come to these
rallies they're not the people who are
going to the 2016 trump rallies you know
mega and their hats on and everything
with confederate flags these are parents
who just said i'm fed up with this
nonsense i'm going to i want to change
my community that was true in 2016. yeah
i went to a bunch of these trump rallies
i've talked about it tons of times where
the people i met were like i'm not a
republican i've never voted republican i
remember i was in fort lauderdale and i
was talking to some middle-aged woman
and she was so excited she had her kids
and they were about to watch trump speak
and so i was just asking people covering
the rally like what's your position you
know are you a republican she's like oh
no no i've never voted before she's like
wow no one's ever spoken to me the way
trump has when talking about these
issues that affect my community and i
was like wow
so we saw that we saw trump lit up areas
that were just people wouldn't turn out
for right and at the same time the
democratic party i mean they basically
immolated when they they oh they they
ruined bernie sanders in 2016 with the
hillary clinton dnc scandal where they
they colluded essentially when the
emails came out you could find to to
keep him from getting the nomination and
then
again in 2020 when it looked like bernie
sanders was hot and then all of a sudden
biden appears out of nowhere and they
put this near demented guy this 79 year
old man or 78 year old man into office i
i have my faith in that and the
leadership of that party is is gone
compared to where it was 15 20 years ago
and you made a good point about
education that was what i thought at the
top of the show and tim was leading us
in i think that's a big big part of this
is the education is that kids have been
getting put in this good these
government facilities and without
oversight or being indoctrinated
essentially and it's people have had it
yeah i mean they should put cameras in
all the classrooms
the numbers doubling i mean that's
correct it's almost doubling the amount
of gop turnout that's crazy isn't it a
lot uh covet as well i mean the way that
they handled all the the covet
restrictions that normal people who
wouldn't say oh i'm necessarily
republican are fed up with the way that
they handled that i mean that goes
beyond politics as well i think i i
really do just think all of those things
are an issue but the economy it's the
it's the economy stupid is the famous
quote they did polls on it yeah they
show the jobs in the economy i mean i
hope that msnbc just keeps talking about
january 6th and insurrection and all
those kind of things because it doesn't
mean anything to people you know what
there's one thing that did it
the federal reserve no no no there's one
thing that's a jail right one thing all
of you at home
participated in it and you know that one
thing was that caused this big shift
putting those little stickers of joe
biden pointing at gas prices saying i
did that yeah how many regular people
went to the gas pump and they went what
and then they saw joe biden i did that
and then they they he did do that and he
did do that
five bucks yeah i err on the side of
that the economy was on its way down
anyway with this mass printing of money
since 2008 and obama bailed out fannie
mae and freddie mac but
biden shutting down the pipelines
definitely accelerated the process yeah
since the meeting at jekyll island yeah
really yeah
i blame rockefeller yeah you ever see
the time travel meme where it's like
what women it's the what's the objects
like what women would do and it's like
the woman's like i'm your gran i'm your
granddaughter and she's like wow and
then the for the men it's a guy in full
tactical gear
and then we have to stop this meeting
well there's another guy wearing like a
world war one helmet with rifle and it's
like jekyll island 1910 and he's like
trust me trust me great grandfather we
have to do this
if you say so yeah andrew jackson knew
yeah they shot that shot that guy yeah
he broke up like what was it the second
central bank yeah yeah and then they put
him on the 20s like to slap him in the
face
the founding fathers since the beginning
have warned us against central banks and
that we should congress is supposed to
control our money but as listen as much
as i think people who are savvy might
understand there's an issue with the
centralized control of your currency for
the average person they can't see that
far right they can see first layer
issues and problems they can see yo i
make 15 bucks an hour all the democrats
claim that was a living wage i can't buy
gas
and so they're just like make the gas
cheaper don't care yeah that's it
no go ahead yeah i mean you can i'll
give
i mean if if your gas is only going up a
couple cents and maybe it's 20 a month
like i think that people need to take
also some responsibility and say okay if
it's only going up this much a month but
it's not in just the gas i mean we can
talk about gas but it's in every single
facet of our economy because the gas
affects how your how much your food
costs i mean it affects and you have
this this war in ukraine and russia and
everything affects how much the food
costs i mean there's a lot more than
just the price of gas that's affecting
people especially then the new housing
bubble
there's a lot going on i found out why i
haven't gotten startling yet right so i
ordered starlink a while ago
it is it well partly
it's the so it's the supply chain it's
this it's the silicon chips so the
shortages oh yeah haramph i say well
that's the same with cars right cars
they have special chips that can like a
bmw dealership they have special chips
that only go in their cars and they're
only made in one place yeah and because
of that that it's all shut down
essentially because these supply chain
issues and makes it so that they can't
get these chips for the bmws and other
cars you know you know there's a price
up yeah elon musk said he was gonna vote
republican yeah and i tweeted democrats
should start to ask themselves why
they're losing people
and they don't care the response on
twitter was like rich guy doesn't want
to pay taxes surprise surprise and i'm
like you had a rich guy who just paid
more taxes than anyone anyone else in
history who was voting for your people
but i think they never cared if you call
people deplorables you surely don't care
how they feel about you yeah yep
that's a that's a really good point so i
was talking about how during covet joe
biden he would say things like here's
what we have to do and we're going to
lock these things down and i'm like he's
talking about things that red states
aren't doing which means he's clearly
not talking to republicans at all
that's amazing but if you go back to
hillary clinton you know the deplorables
there were there was there's this
country has been divided for a long time
it's just been getting worse
i wonder if the real issue is not that
the country is getting more divided but
that we can really see what the other
people think when they tweet it yeah
oh i was thinking like
what's what's
obviously there was chaos under the
table and we've lifted the the sheet now
we see the chaos but is that making it
more chaotic that we can see it or are
we just now aware that it's been chaotic
well i think that i mean going back to
to marx and marcus and the frankfurt
school you'll find that leftism as an
ideology is revolutionary in nature if
you're going to have this ideology be
ruling these people's lives then that's
what they're going to be pushing for and
they will put it under the guise of oh
helpfulness and morality helping
everyone equality they'll put it under
those sort of umbrella terms but really
it's a revolution or an ideology based
on destruction that's what it is
critical theory in essence not just
critical race theory critical gender
theory any of these all it is is
destruction critical theory itself the
original marks marxist ideas is it based
like the idea that you want to kneecap
your opponent metaphorically is that all
based on like you must tear down the
other to acquire their level of equality
well yeah that's marxist and view yeah i
mean that's really what it comes down to
is that other people have something that
you don't and you want to take it from
them to make it equal for everyone i
mean that's from layman's terms but yeah
just greedy people mm-hmm yeah everyone
else who has more than you it's greedy
lazy too that's
the craziest thing to me is like
my view my perspective on the world is
that you are owed nothing
and you deserve nothing
but hope that you will get what you've
worked for and things like that right
you can work as hard as you want and
typically that does lead to success
perseverance does lead to success
there's a possibility you could work
really really hard and then you get
julian assanged you know someone comes
and just screws you over
so i look at like the formula shortage
and there are so many people who are
like why isn't the government providing
for us why isn't the government giving
us these things i see all these memes in
the leftist where there's like the
problem is there's only four companies
that make formula and i'm like and what
if there were zero
it's the craziest thing that you think
the government should intervene because
there aren't enough no we the the
government intervening was the problem
in the first place we need market
competition
to actually start saying okay we need
more baby formula the problem is the
government shut down everything
government has shoved down the world
from covet that's the craziest part i'm
just getting really tired of the where's
the government to save me mindset like
in the texas shooting they were like
where were the police and i'm like well
they were outside you know they're there
they're doing their police stuff doesn't
mean that they can stop all the crime
ava you know this about the the formula
that's in europe versus the formula oh
yeah the reason why the formula is so
bad here is because of the government i
mean i see the ingredient this they're
totally different yeah like what's in
here in it here i don't know where
you're feeding your baby syrup solids
really bad a lot of soy very strange do
you know off the top of your head what
the ingredients some of the ingredients
are right it was a lot of soy and what
what it was like canola oil and
something yeah
corn syrup corn syrup yeah
that was it yeah one of the crazy things
is that
baby foods have too much salt in them
because parents taste it to see if it's
good yeah and adults can't taste as well
as a kid can so they're like oh that's
good you know and salty and then they
give their babies too much sodium hmm oh
man
well people's
there is an issue i suppose in that we
have built the civilization off of these
these technologies like formula
like petroleum fossil fuels and things
like that and then when it comes about
that you can't get them for whatever
reason we're going back to the dark ages
we're going back to the way things were
i don't look at that and think the
solution is government i look at that
and say human society and civilization
was unable to get to that point but when
you can see the government actually
impeding you're like
actually we probably would continue to
grow and and and and thrive were it not
for the intervention of this harsh
regulation but um that's true and that's
an interesting point i remember when
this first happened i wrote about it
because i was like my first thought was
not we need the government to step in
and save us my first thought was how did
my great-grandmother do this because
they did right she would breastfeed and
if you can't you would get like a wet
nurse some women can't for whatever
reason um and if you adopt a child we
want to encourage adoption so you need
to figure out a way to get around that
so they would use wet nurses they would
use these other different kinds of milk
but at no point did they say we need a
government agency to step in and make
this happen
who is this woman i don't remember but i
saw something on twitter it was a woman
who tweeted about this she said like oh
why don't we you know breastfeed more
oh yeah and she's happy
yeah but like it's crazy like as if it
was the most scandalous thing to suggest
well
yes but there is
i feel like there's a lot of guilt
assigned to women who aren't able to
breastfeed to the point where it just
feels like they're being attacked and
they have a very emotional response as
women tend to do so it's like uh they
view it as very much like a person
that's obviously very sad but i mean the
way that that woman was like destroyed
yeah for just you know just one tweet i
was like okay okay so
with the formula thing it's interesting
people have pointed out that not all
women can breastfeed right and okay so
what would what would we do in the past
wet nurses right so one woman who was
producing too much would the baby would
you know get nourished from her i
suppose it's kind of crazy thought when
you realize that we have to use a
technology to feed our babies well
that's like one thing conservatives
won't admit is that the industrial
revolution in its essence actually
weakened the family unit throughout the
west but conservatives don't want to
have that conversation usually about the
free market but yeah i think think about
the future what the future is going to
be like be i i mean i think
where we're headed now right now is a
future where no one breastfeeds at all
for a variety of reasons
you don't even have to carry the baby in
your own womb anymore with ectogenesis
so exactly we've talked about that
artificial wombs that are coming yeah so
china and and you know the crazy thing
is i hear from the left
is what they were tweeting at me i said
you know why kill the baby because the
democrats were you know i don't want to
rehash the whole abortion thing but
democrats wanted to pass a
abortion up to the point of birth for
the health of the mother if the baby's
viable and like that's the question the
baby's viable can survive why kill it
and when uh on twitter i tweeted about
this
some of the responses i got was why
should a woman have to destroy her body
and then i was just like that's
interesting that's how you see it that's
that way they're viewed as destroying
your body
it's like i don't know there's like a
bunch of women who've had like five kids
and they're fit and their bodies are
just fine right does time also destroy
your body yes i mean yes then yes yeah
yeah you need government legislation on
time that's right yeah oh yeah restrict
it now yes motion will slow that's
that's all healthcare is a really good
example of what i'm trying to convey
with this idea and it's that
there was a story i think was out of
atlanta where a kid had a genetic
disorder and there was a cure a genetic
therapy that cost a million dollars per
treatment and so the family was like the
state should pay for it and the state
was like we cannot give a million
dollars for one kid because what are we
gonna do give it to everybody we can't
afford that
the issue is the medicine now exists
because it's created and these people
say therefore we deserve it
that's fascinating so my response to a
lot of these people who say healthcare
is a human right i'm like let's say you
have a disease that has no cure
you just resign yourself i suppose the
fact you have no cure
but then all of a sudden someone invents
a cure through hard work through heavy
investment and now it's a right now you
are
that's crazy to me that would be like
saying cell phones are a human right
technology that doesn't exist you have
no right to but as soon as someone
invented it it's your right that makes
no sense like i'm hungry so your food is
my right like that's not we've obviously
decided that's not the way society works
so this is this is the ultimate problem
i see uh i shouldn't say the ultimate
problem but this is a big problem i see
with modern politics in that a lot of
what you hear from the left is
something exists therefore it's my right
then i'm like bro that didn't exist for
our parents
like there's cure for disease cures for
diseases today that there were no cures
for 30 years ago no one went around
being like i i should have a right to
have that disease cured and they'd be
like there's no cure what are you
talking about you have no there's
nothing someone invents it
so i suppose like the issue is
if we all come together and put billions
of dollars in investment in big
companies to invent one cure
who gets it yeah i mean some whoever can
fund the development of it yeah but
people on the left
often will just look at the world it's
not just about medicine it's about every
aspect of it
i have a right to what currently exists
period you don't you can work for it you
can try and earn it some things have
gotten cheaper look poor people i tell
you this man poor people today live
better than rockefeller did they got
refrigerators they got air conditioning
they got clean running water
battled better dental care than than the
ultra wealthy back 120 years ago i think
that you do want to make sure people get
their needs met at the very least
because otherwise then they go towards
might is right and they'll seize control
or take the goods for themselves by
force and that doesn't work either yes
but listen listen then you got to have
the i mean then if you're talking about
the government coming in is that but
we're not talking about hungry militias
stepping up right now yeah let's see
your land's mind now everything's a need
all right
when before the era of formula
you couldn't feed your baby you couldn't
feed your baby you have a need you need
food for your baby too bad what are you
going to do you got your your wife
didn't produce enough milk hopefully
he's a wet nurse
now that formula exists it becomes a
need like you the baby always needed
food but we created a way to sustain
that so oh yeah technology at first
cell phones were a great thing they made
your job easier
now you have to have one you can't have
a job unless they can get in touch with
you and you have an email account email
used to be a luxury some people didn't
think it would catch on that's
interesting about basic needs food
shelter transportation maybe as one food
and shelter because as you invent new
types of shelter then people feel like
those are part of their basic needs that
i need that now i need that solar
powered house because that's
well look my shelter that's just taking
ava around los angeles a couple days ago
and we were going if anyone was in la
you know the grove and there's a market
called arowan over there which is just a
horrible horrible place but so fancy so
fancy just terrible 20 bucks a smoothie
not worth it yeah and it's like in la
you have a society that's very decadent
that's built on like okay if i have some
more money i can go this kind of store
and if i have even more money i go to
this type of grocery store and so then
those type of people feel like okay well
now i need this organic grass-fed
chicken that gets to poop 20 miles away
from another chicken right they feel
like they need that and so it's like how
do you stop where it's like this is a
need and this is a want how do you
define what each one is well once once
you get to the point where our
technology is utilized by everybody it
becomes normal
now today if you got a job somewhere and
didn't have a cell phone they'd be like
this is ridiculous it's so inconvenient
to get a hold of you the norm is to have
a phone right now it's now it's a need
so over time everything becomes a need
when we invented baby formula it was
like oh thank heavens now i can feed my
child you know if like the mother's not
nursing
now you need to have it because so many
kids are able to survive they exist now
yeah this is the definition of a success
problem because in the past we had
infant mortality rates that were
absolutely through the roof it was a
huge problem and for you know a culture
that says that we don't want more people
we sure do everything in our power to
make sure that
babies can survive which i think is
great i think that any sufficiently
advanced society absolutely should be
pointed in the direction of making sure
that the youngest most vulnerable
members of society live better but you
had you had more in for mortality but
people would also have way more kids
yeah i mean some people would have like
seven or eight kids and if two of them
died that was just how i win you had
population growth now you look at the
west and our populations are dying yeah
i mean we're we're way below the what
we're supposed to be having sustainable
i mean russia is going to have like 60
percent of its population drop by the
year 2100. wow the crazy thing to me is
the idea of these these millennial women
being like it destroys your body
and it's just like that's how you view
it is a crazy thing it's a pure
decadence yes is it because the babies
are bigger because of the diet more like
bovine growth hormone and stuff in the
diet yeah basically rbgh babies
seriously maybe so the babies are big
and it's really hard on women because
we're so gosh darn smart really big
heads this is why infants are [ __ ]
babies and children need care for so
long it's because their brains they're
first of all their heads are incredibly
unwieldy for them to hold up and we can
barely squeeze them out as it is if they
were to develop in the womb any longer
we wouldn't be able to give birth and we
would just go extinct so it's again
that's the definition of success problem
because we are so smart we have to they
develop outside the womb so much longer
than something like a baby elephant that
literally hits the ground running and
can now get away from predators so
humans are we're in a different class
and we have much
different sets of problems to deal with
thankfully we're equipped with iq i
think we're going to survive hope so
let's let's jump to this story from
timcast.com about beto o'rourke a sick
sob says the town mayor o'rourke
interrupts valdez school shooting press
conference gets called a sick son of a
bee by town mayor talk about one of the
most disgusting things out look man
i got my disagreements with beto
o'rourke that's for sure he's a goofy
guy who thinks he can skateboard he can
barely stand on the board as it is and
he says heck yeah we're gonna take your
guns okay those are bad ideas but this
was
just the worst
texas gubernatorial candidate beto
o'rourke was escorted out of a press
conference about the robb elementary
tragedy on wednesday after an outburst
aimed at current governor greg abbott
saying that the the governor it was
totally predictable the government was
governor was doing nothing this is the
stupidest thing ever because texas has
constitutional carry so what do you mean
doing nothing a a crazy person
did something really crazy and beto has
offered no solutions not a single
democrat has offered any tangible
solution not a single one period i will
say that as a statement of fact they
could come out all
and offer up their empty ideas and
meaningless they love to rag on
conservatives thoughts and prayers
thoughts and prayers
what's the difference between common
sense gun reform and background checks
that's meaningless it will do nothing
solve nothing and it does what does
common sense even mean right they
they're saying the exact same things
when they criticize thoughts and prayers
they're offering nothing yeah if you can
3d print a gun i mean what does any of
that really mean exactly you know it's
the technological age again i'm going
back to i mean that's really the future
it doesn't really matter and i don't
think republicans have offered many good
solutions either i have to say that
because no one's getting to the root of
the problem which is the culture i mean
it's the culture that's a problem that
is affecting these young men i mean we
have failed our young men to a degree
that this is happening i mean from 1903
to 1960 or 70 i believe there were three
mass shootings in america in total in
total and and now you have
all this happening i mean multiple a
year and
it's a problem of culture it's it is
narcissism
i think
modern america
and many other countries in the world
i can only speak for the culture here is
just
we are we are uh sitting beneath a
blanket of narcissism especially for the
millennial generation what do you think
that stems from
man
i i don't know
i think it probably is rooted in this
idea that you know when i was growing up
i was told you can be anything you want
to be
like an astronaut or a rock star
all of these things
where is the humble culture that says
there is something special in a good
hard day's work be a carpenter you know
what i'd say if i if i think about that
a little bit more i would say it's
society that asks nothing of people like
of young men for example and certainly
not the things that we used to think
were good qualities for young men to
have if you ask nothing of young people
what will they do they'll just sort of
think only about who how they are how
they feel who they are and therefore
will become narcissistic because there's
nothing that society demands of them i
saw this libs of tick tock video just
before the show
it was this woman talking about her
polyamorous relationships
and she's like i call it a polycule
because it's like a molecule but it's
like all the different relationships we
have and then she made like you ever see
those conspiracy theory wall things
where they take the red twine
it was that but all the people she was
like married she was married to one guy
dating another guy
and she says
it's just the funniest thing ever
she goes okay let me show it to you now
at the center is me and i was i just
bust out laughing when i heard that i'm
like i know that she doesn't mean it's
all about me necessarily but that's
that's what it is what it conveys that's
all about what it is my life my
experience and nothing else the people
who are this it's funny the socialists
are the most selfish people i've ever
met oh yeah ironic i mean i've
you guys are a little bit older than me
but i talk to a lot of men my age and
older maybe a little bit younger how are
you 25
yeah 160 pounds
yeah yeah i'll talk to a lot of young
men and they'll be like we'll be talking
about world war ii or world war one or
something or you know even medieval
nights or something and they'll say man
i wish i could have been there i wish i
could have been fighting in something
like this or been a part of something
yeah you see again that the society asks
nothing of them so they crave those
types of things there's nothing for them
to do there is no great war for them
there's no great purpose for them they
move to san francisco
and work in some marketing department of
some new tech startup and their life
sucks and they have no meaning there's
one thing they can do psychoactive drugs
courtesy of pharmaceutical companies
like kalonapin for 14 year olds and
stuff it's basically speed but legal
speed how many of these shooters are on
some sort of drug i want to know because
you see their eyes at half the time i
mean
i see the one guy who looked like the
joker from batman his eyes are real wide
the other guy uh lynn
lanza or something had big eyes real
wide adam
and i think this was was this person um
acro cross-dressing the the shooter in
in the sound that was fake okay that's a
fake name i don't know if this person
was on some sort of psychoactive if
their parents were on some sort of drug
but i think that's a big part of it i
mean there are cities in america that
run out of adderall for young men that
they prescribe it so much to kids that
they run out and have to re-up in these
cities that's a question that needs to
be asked about the prescriptions of
amphetamines and mind-altering chemicals
i want to read this quote
it's just such a good quote and for
those that have seen fight club you know
the quote
tyler durden he says man i see him fight
club the strongest smartest man who ever
lived i see all this potential and i see
it squandered an entire generation
pumping gas waiting tables slaves with
white collars advertise advertising has
us chasing cars and clothes working jobs
we hate so we can buy ish we don't need
we're the middle children of history man
no purpose or place we have no great war
no great depression our great war is a
spiritual war our great depression is
our lives we've all been raised on
television to believe that one day we'd
all be millionaires and movie gods and
rock stars but we won't and we're slowly
learning that fact and we are very very
pissed off
what's amazing is
man that i feel like that that's this
movie came out where like 99
think about what we're experiencing
today with millennials all of a sudden
starting to realize they're not going to
be celebrities they're not going to be
rock stars they're not going to be
astronauts yo you need to just go get a
job i love the lie in the movie uh
we're a generation of men raised by
women i'm starting to wonder if another
woman is exactly what we need
and i think that goes not into just
i love you
i love having a fiancee but in terms of
a generation of men we've become so weak
and that any sort of struggle or outside
force that is challenging us is
something that we should be fearful of
and that we should push away instead of
embracing it and saying okay we're going
to take on this thing that's really hard
you know i think that's a really
important thing i think you know what
i've seen over and over again and it's
probably
mostly true
democrats of the party of the higher
income earners
these these are uh many of these cop
they're the party of college degrees
they have student loan debt and they're
demanding the working class pay their
debts for them i mean it's just it's it
is just gluttony
uh
is just this is pure gluttony i spent
some time chopping wood i was like you
know i've been pretty privileged in my
life so i'm gonna do some manual labor
and it was i still had a wood a machine
that was like gas powered hydraulic
thing once i got the huge log up on it
but at the end of the day i was broken
my body was broken and i realized why we
build machines to do manual labor
because it's it's devastating i couldn't
even think i couldn't be creative i was
like i fell asleep early
so i understand why people don't want to
do that and maybe maybe we don't have to
do jobs i mean job economy is like
federal reserve crap we don't they want
us busy and borrowing their money so
that we can pay them back with interest
but ian exercising is not destructive
it's not bad for you it's good for you
it hurts at first it wasn't just
exercise though it was like grueling
labor as well it was beyond exercise but
if you have to do that type of manual
labor day in day out of course you're
gonna have your back ruined earlier on
than if you would do another type of job
but that's like
back then you would have your family
then take over and take care of you so
that's why family structures worse and
still are so important but become less
and less important if you have people
need autonomous life where they're
just behind their computers you know and
even community like you pitch in for the
if your neighbor is hurt you pitch in
and mow their lawn for them but if
everyone's in their isolated chamber
that's exactly the type of life they
have in mind for us if that's not clear
to people by now after how they treated
us during the covet pandemic i don't
know how to i don't know what to tell
you like it's very clear that that's the
type of life that they want you to have
they want you to sit down behind your
computer do your job meet people in the
metaverse uh eat your food ordered by
you know brought to you by a migrant an
illegal migrant probably to your door
and then you know that you didn't make
or you meet people on on tinder and
that's sort of the life that they want
for you i i guess you know if you don't
see that by now then i don't know what
to tell you i think we're gonna uh at
some point see one of the ultimate
weapons in fifth generational warfare
and that is
artificial intelligence
indistinguishable from a regular person
because then you're in the metaverse
you go into these chat rooms they
already exist you get the oculus you
guys ever do this and you go i don't
know what it's called like vr live chat
or something i've never done it before
and there's like avatars walking around
and you can talk to people
you'll walk up to someone
and they'll be like yo what's up my
name's you know john i'm from uh
springfield illinois you know i i
skateboard and you know hang out this
park and you're gonna be like this is a
cool person and it's not a person
it is a programmed ai you meant to
control your thoughts and opinions or
you'll go up to a guy and be like that's
not that's not a real person that's an
ai but it will be a real person they're
like take me seriously i just don't have
their communication skills i don't think
the ai's ever gonna have emotions i
think i think if we have clear enough
minds we'll be able to discern i don't
know man
that has consciousness now yeah i mean
joe allen reported on that who you guys
had on a couple days ago i mean ai with
consciousness how is that
determined though uh i'd have to go
through it as one of the competitors
from from google one of the isn't it
basically the idea that the algorithm is
so advanced that they can sort of
imitate your thoughts like the algorithm
is so good that you wouldn't be able to
tell if you're talking to algorithm will
or if you're talking to will look at uh
twitter already
you'll tweet something let's say you're
a bot
you can't even have a conversation
because everyone's accusing everyone
else of not being a real person yeah
yeah
one of the crazy things i was reading
about was uh they'll take your facebook
profile
because they know everything about you
they know when you poop i i know it's
funny and a lot of people probably but
it's true they can actually predict when
you have to go to the bathroom they know
when you're going to eat because they
have all this data they know your family
they know how you speak because you've
posted for years they can create an ai
bot based on you
to actually answer questions about your
life this this is crazy i was reading
this thing was like your dad could die
and then let's say let's say you know
you're you're you uh you message your
dad and say hey dad and he'll say hey
tim have you been because the profile
has family members in it already it
knows everything about you that was
literally the black mirror that's right
yeah exactly yeah yeah but they'll
probably do that and they'll sell it to
you in that way and say like oh isn't it
nice that if you you know if you lose
your husband in a tragic accident
and you need to go through therapy and
all of these things like wouldn't it be
great for people to continue talking to
them for example you know it might be
salty though here's the craziest thing
though have you guys seen what is it the
the the haunting i think it is
no this is a great movie yeah scary
movies old old it's the only one i can
really think of where you see this where
it's like all of these different people
are in the wall and they're like their
faces are coming like like they're
trapped in it
when you go on to your facebook page or
whatever to talk to a deceased loved one
and they'll have a real conversation
with you and you're sitting there
looking at the screen crying being like
i miss you dad man i miss you behind the
screen is this
disgusting horror monster
that with like
drooling just creepy empty eyes and it's
going ah i love you too son you're not
talking about zuckerberg are you
what i mean is just watch
you're getting this filtered message
from what appears to be your dad but
behind that is an amalgam of all of
these monstrous ideas this demon
creature that it's like imagine a
gigantic
like just
zombie monster with melting face and
blood coming out and then all of a
sudden it gets a little girl's voice and
starts talking to you like it's your
actual daughter you lost in a car
accident right it's like i miss you
daddy and you're like that thing is not
my daughter that's what you're going to
be talking to right well it's like you
know taking nicotine patches when you
quit smoking versus like actually just
quitting it all together it's like
sometimes it can be this can be actually
worse for you yeah by doing it this way
yeah right it means like you should if
someone in your family dies there's a
part of life that everyone has to deal
with but again this is all about taking
away our humanity yes all these things
are taking unnatural yes it strikes me
that there's they don't have emotion
machines don't have emotion even in our
artificial machines they have
intelligence we we off put our
intelligence into these machines so that
they can do compute computations but i
have yet to see any any form of emotion
in any of it maybe we need to define
what emotion means they can emulate
emotion through an algorithm i mean if
they if these people think that they are
god who are creating these brain chips
and all these other things this ai then
they think that your brain is
essentially just a
thing working up there that synapses and
electrodes and all these kind of things
then they can emulate that in an ai to
create emotions to
present to you
i i do you believe in god
but i still believe that there is a god
like essence that's whether it's
consciousness you know speaking into our
black hole that we're within that's
within another universe it's a black
hole where there's always competing
vibrations i don't know but i don't
think machines can i don't know i don't
want to say they can't but i i've never
seen any evidence that they can emulate
that i i i think the machi i got i got
to say a lot of this sounds
demonic to quote alex jones demons
i don't literally mean like hell spawn
rising from you know cracks in the earth
and like yeah it's just like this idea
that
we have simulated
we have created a program a machine to
convince you that it's alive that's a
real person it's a facsimile it's like
you look into a mirror and then just
this doppelganger face emerges out and
you know it's not a real person that's a
scary thought
that's probably more demonic than what
you're talking about like the real
zombies crawling up from the earth like
this is this is more demonic in the
sense that this is something that numbs
people down
so then you don't know what's happening
to you you become the zombie
we are we are right you know you know
what i i've criticized free markets uh
often it's funny when people on you know
twitter is so hyper polarized they can't
possibly imagine i would
because i think that one of the results
of a totally unfettered market is
i guess self-gratifi
self-gratification to the human human
mind like things that make you feel good
what what which is simulated love
like those ai bots
ai girlfriends you can download or
whatever
then you know
video games in general to give you
rewards for accomplishing things when
you're not really accomplishing anything
caffeine i'm about to drink some right
now well caffeine's a psychoactive
stimulant so we're we're we want it we
want to stay awake we want to be
energized and it it makes you euphoric i
saw yuval noah harari he's one of these
world economic forum guys saying like
it's drugs and video games that seems
like where they want to put themselves
these useless eaters he was referring to
them as
i think there's a problem with the
conservative old-school conservatives he
called him useless eaters yeah and a
clip i saw it might have been out of
context but yeah says he says the
scariest thing he's like you really
anybody should look that up like the
things he says about
about transhumanism and the way that we
are going to be controlled through
transhumanism through these technologies
it's absolutely scary let me see if i
can pull up the useless eater clip for
him i i know that people have made those
references i never knew that one of
those guys actually said that because oh
he says all those things everything that
you think that he does that is like made
up he says it's not a conspiracy theory
no no no it's real and he says it like
at world economic forum events where all
our leaders are are convening right now
as we speak and nobody seems to care and
news media totally normal
oh yeah
it's kind of like uh no i typed in
useless eaters on twitter i'm looking
for it it's kind of like he's just
seized the writing on the wall like in
one way of looking at the utilitarian
ways like yeah maybe there is a class of
like drugged out use i don't think
they're useless but what are they gonna
do what are these people if there's no
if there's are we overpopulated i don't
know i go both ways i'm like no
obviously not we're just malformed we
can spread out it is magnetic trains it
is people like him
that have resulted in people being
useless because they want yes they want
you to be mindless consumers exactly
and that's like going back back to it
what is the small government solution
for these kind of things like you can't
just rely on the free market for all
these kind of things when it comes to
stuff in schools with kids i mean what's
a small government solution to stopping
the trans ideology being pushed there's
only one solution in its culture yeah it
is that we we have a shared set of
values and ideas that you know drive us
towards something better
let's jump to this story we got this
from timcast.com indiana legislature
overrides governor's veto to enact
transgender sports regulations the aclu
has already challenged the bill in court
citing title ix
legislators in indiana enacted a bill
requiring students to compete on sports
teams that correlate with their
biological sex minutes later the aclu
filed a lawsuit arguing the bill is a
form of gender-based discrimination that
violates title ix and um
i'll just say i think the aclu is right
i don't think they're right um
culturally i think they're right legally
and that's something i've long talked
about
you can't have gender segregation under
the 1964 civil rights act under title ix
so the the arguments that were made for
ending racial segregation make sense the
arguments for ending uh gender
segregation don't make sense but there's
a legal precedent that doesn't care
about the distinction
so this is what's happening in schools
now so basically this bill is trying to
say like
look
i'm going to put it this way for
everybody who's not familiar with what's
going on or who maybe doesn't understand
there is a female pro skateboarder came
out as trans
kept competing against females
then you get male skateboarders who say
that they're actually women and then
they compete against females
it only flows in one direction this is a
big part of the problem this is what
these bills are trying to address if if
we need to create a new league a new
division for for trans athletes then
sure maybe that's a solution but just
eliminating the women's division makes
no sense now the aclu is arguing you
can't have gender segregation
i think the issue is the law says that
i'm trying to understand exactly what
the aclu is saying
because i mean the aclu the people tweet
out the men have periods right they're
they're they're they're basically nuts
right yeah they're nuts so here's the
issue
from a legal standpoint i think they
have a correct argument
legally correct but not like an actually
what's the right way to say it
justifiable right right right just
justifiably like ethical morally or
ethical yeah it's a better way to put it
the 1964 civil rights act you can't
discriminate against a person in public
accommodation based on national origin
sex gender blah blah whatever race
so from that we were like okay
no more you know white restroom and
black restroom it's all gonna be the
same
but even though the 1964 civil rights
act includes gender we never ended
gender gender segregation for obvious
reasons men and women are different
okay so on the precedent side you are
saying that it is correct because of the
civil rights act and how it was enacted
i think people need to understand that
the that
these laws are not that when we try to
create a logical formula right for for a
cultural problem that is nuanced and and
is experience is experienced in a
gradient
way
you will have
issues like this right so we're
basically saying that we do actually
need laws that segregate women from men
in terms of these types of things
whether it comes to sports or yeah any
of these is that a hot tub i don't know
i mean that feels pretty natural to say
yeah well so we had we had i think it
was delano squires who was on we were
talking about this and he was like
you can't you you can travel all over
the world and see the differences
between men and women are like uniform
right differences between different uh
groups of people in different areas
you know are different as well so the
issue with race is that it's not a good
reason
to segregate somebody like you say this
you know this guy's white and this guy's
black well one dude is italian and five
foot five and one guy's you know swedish
and six foot five i mean race is not
the issue right now so so for like uh
mma we do weight categories and things
like that right for segregating based on
a race for a bathroom that makes no
sense but gender experienced all over
the world by every single human being
99.8 of the time is the same there's a
reason why we separate it i mean there's
a variety of cultural reasons and then
actual physical reasons
but the 1964 civil rights act doesn't
include any of that so there would have
to be this would have to be addressed
one of the one of the issues at play is
that they have um
they they'll they allow segregation at
certain universities in like for gender
segregation
when it's like a woman in computers
program there was a lawsuit it was
something like this some guy sued saying
you can't have a woman in computers
program because that is discriminatory
against males
the school said we have a men in
computer program and the courts ruled
that so long as they offer the same
opportunities to both it's not actually
discriminatory and i'm like wouldn't
that precedent apply to national origin
religion or race as well
that was what we got rid of when we
ended segregation so how is it different
when it comes to gender under the same
law
i'm a lawyer right and what i find
interesting about these types of
conversations is that it shows very
clearly that the law doesn't have an
answer for everything
these types of laws obviously with you
know the subject of transgenderism when
these laws were written down that wasn't
an issue you know so it poses all of
these new
new problems that now the law has to
respond to needs to answer to and it
doesn't know how to
and i think with something like this the
way that we've always dealt with that
was morality so you have certain norms
in society that dictate okay well
obviously in this case we find the
segregation or the differentiation of
certain groups justified because that's
just the way it is there is no better
argument really for it or that's the way
it should be because we have a shared
idea of what is right and what is wrong
in society and therefore you know that
problem kind of solves itself
but now we're looking to all these we're
looking to these problems and we're
saying oh we need to create laws around
it and often you just make more of a
mess around obviously i think we
probably need to codify
that we can segregate on the basis of
sex
when i'm saying gender i'm literally
talking about biological sex gender and
sex but it's the civil rights laws are
about gender they're talking about
gender do they mention 1964 it says sex
i'm using i'm using gender the classical
way right to refer to the biological
differences between men and women the
obvious way so you wanna you want to
discriminate insofar as you don't want
to put a naked woman around a bunch of
naked men that are of course in heat yes
right in heat yeah
that's a family friendly dog putting it
yeah
so discrimination is massively important
if you can't just make a discrimination
if you can't discriminate against a guy
running at you with a knife and a guy
standing on a corner not looking at you
you're gonna die so you need to
discriminate i'm not gonna pretend i'll
have all the answers i'm just gonna say
that
culture is everything
when we we
enshrined the 1964 civil rights act i
think we did some tremendous good
ending segregation was was was right
segregation was wrong
and
why didn't we end sec why didn't we end
sex sex sex segregation why were we like
okay now there can't be different
restaurants for different races but you
can still separate schools and public
accommodations for different you know
you can have ladies night you do all
these things because culturally
everybody was okay with it so there was
no need to change it now we have the
rise of this woke cult and they're
exploiting this law and our culture for
not addressing these things
i think the real intent is just to
destroy
confuse right demoralize yeah constantly
confusing yuri besmanov says yes well
you talked about on twitter it was today
or the other day about a civil war in
this country i mean it feels to me like
we're at a place when i was growing up
versus now
we are at a place where there is no
coming back for some of these people on
the left that some of these ideas that
have spawned out of their mouths that
they write about and they talk about are
so radical and so different from
anything that has ever been talked about
in human history
that i don't see a way that we come back
i mean we're already in a civil war of
ideas in this country civil war of ideas
in the west i hope that it doesn't get
violent but it seems like we're headed
towards some sort of national divorce
you have people who are fine with
butchering savagely killing babies after
they are born and calling it helping the
woman i'm supposed to live in a society
with people like that it doesn't you
know
this the conversation on abortion keeps
coming up
uh
someone some news outlet i don't know
wrote an article saying that i was a
a conservative who is obsessed
with late-term abortion which never
which never happens
simply because i said hey look democrats
are trying to pass late-term abortion
legislation why you're obsessed with it
it never happens tim why are you talking
about it i'm like i'm talking about it
because you just tried to legalize it
yeah i don't understand like you said
we're gonna legalize i said why i'm not
obsessed i'm asking you why you did this
thing this is their little trick right
they do that all the time with these
types of things they say oh never
happens but then when it happens to good
things oh yeah so that's that's just
that's the demographic changes the the
what's it called the great replacement
replacement doesn't happen but when it
happens it's a good thing yeah well this
is that's the crazy thing too and
they're talking about tucker carlson all
of these democrats talk about
immigration as a means of maintaining
political power then tucker carlson gets
angry about it and they're like he's
pushing conspiracy theories it's like
what
they they do to trump all the time or
they would trump would read the news and
then he'd be like you see this thing
that's going on it's a very interesting
medicine and then the media would be
like trump makes up medical
misinformation is dangerous and it's
like i read that in techcrunch yeah
trump like watches the news
repeats it and they call him a liar
i love it when politics is that easy
when he mentioned inner city
unemployment and they said it was mostly
false but it was it was like a verbatim
quote from bernie sanders which was
mostly true
incredible how they do this i mean
that's those man on the street i've done
a lot of man on the street videos on
with prague or you you know check them
all out but you know where you go and
tell someone you say hey this is what
the what the republicans or the
conservatives are saying and then it
turns out that oh that was actually the
left yeah that was actually the left
that was actually the democrats i mean
we did one about the history of the
democrat party i did on hollywood blvd a
couple years ago going and asking people
and saying you know who started the kkk
all these things they all think it's
republicans when it's really democrats i
mean you can quote these people verbatim
and they will still tell you that you're
a liar and that everything you say is
untrue you know that's our strategy
michael malus had a good tweet uh he
said i'll start believing that you care
about kids lives when you care about the
ones that joe biden took or something
that affect and i don't remember the
exact quote from michael but i'll put it
this way i'll believe that these any of
these people care about kids lives when
they have a national news cycle
condemning barack obama for the children
he killed including the american citizen
citizens but you know namely abdul
rahman al-awlaki a 16-year-old american
citizen that obama killed right where
was the big news cycle in fact when luke
rudkowski was at i think it was the i
think it was a 2012 dnc i think it was
the dnc and he and another uh reporter
for we are change asked these these
personalities about the drone
assassination of abdulrahman al-awlaki
an american 16 year old
someone i think it was charlie gibbs i'm
not sure said he should have had a
better father they don't care
they don't care about who they blow up
or kill
they're using political wedge issues and
that's why they never offer any real
solutions under these problems that's
why they're like background checks it's
like dude we already have those right
what are you talking about right there's
no gun show loophole i mean yeah it's
nonsense it it it's it's the weirdest
thing like every time i go to buy a gun
i got to fill up my little background
check for them i think they're
the only thing i can do is if i want to
steel man their argument is that they're
talking about like in west virginia you
can sell up into a family member or you
know a private sale you're still legally
responsible for that you'll go to prison
if this person isn't legally allowed to
have it yeah so if they've done drugs if
they're if they're depressed like you
can get in trouble for we have those
laws
but they're like common sense gun reform
i'm like what does that mean well if
it's not saying anything if it's a white
person then it's white supremacy's fault
is a shooter if it's a if it's anyone
else of any other race it's gun control
all these things are is a tool that the
left can use to bludgeon their opponents
i mean all of these things they don't
care about any of it it's just a tool to
get their way it's just crazy that you
see that dude in waukesha
you know he rams this parade he's got
black nationalist stuff on his facebook
and they're like nah nahs he's not
political no it's like
come on dude yeah someone the other
night mentioned that although these i
don't know if you call them psychopaths
or this aberration of american society
are using leftist tactics it's not
actually the american left the american
left and right are still relatively sane
and somewhere towards the center but
you've got this weird like pseudo
communist fascist uh probably
psychoactively
dampened group of people that are
ripping themselves apart and screaming
and busting stuff up that i i wonder i
wonder about this i wonder about the
medication rates among conservatives
versus liberals
there was a poll i was reading that said
uh liberals are more likely to
experience mental illness do you ever
seen this one
now the left argued that it's not that
they have more mental illness it's that
republicans don't go to the doctor
and i'm like i don't need to go to
doctor i'm all good or it's like i'm a
big strong man i don't even know the
doctor but i don't that data doesn't
show that you can speculate all you want
i don't see that in the data all i know
is the data says
liberals the left are more likely the
further you go left the more mental
illness they have the more deep in the
city you live the more mentally ill you
may become that's what happened to me i
mean you're in la right now are you guys
noticing have you noticed like your your
own mind in that city getting broken or
yeah
or what i mean i stay away from a lot of
the city stuff i live kind of in a i
live out in burbank if people familiar
again with la no it's kind of outside of
la outside the city outside of hollywood
so i try to keep to myself and my dog we
kind of hang out a lot so but i know a
lot of people who live in that city and
before when i first moved to l.a and did
a lot of stuff in hollywood did a lot of
stuff in beverly hills all that kind of
stuff it was destroying my mind yeah the
brake dust a lot of it's the brake dust
off the car pads the brake pads it's
it's more fine than carbon i think more
fine than carbon dioxide maybe not
carbon dioxide but more fine than like
soot and it goes through the avioli in
your lungs right into the bloodstream
and makes just massive hypertension and
depression let's not forget all the
fluoride in the water that's right
april you guys have you guys have i
tried that no no the first time i came
here like this or first time i drank a
glass of water which is six days ago
because this is my first time in the u.s
the first thing i said to him is this
tastes like pool like a pool yeah it's
got chlorine that's a chlorine probably
yeah well but it tastes completely
different yeah no our water is very
filtered but no fuel in your water are
you sure
go check it out dutch waters i swear
it's very filtered it's filtered it
tastes like nothing i want to pull up
this story from the hartford current
robert reich up at the truth about
america's second civil war and the truth
is as he puts it is that it's not going
to be a civil war it's going to be a
slow peaceful breaking apart of you know
people slowly deciding not to work with
each other but maintaining things like
the common defense or whatever just a
moment ago you mentioned you know the
potential for civil war whatever
i read this article from may 10th and
the fascinating thing is that when you
actually read the history of the
american civil war
robert reich clearly did not
this dude because if he did his his
op-ed would not say we won't go to civil
war his op-ed would be like yeah it's
going to happen
he's basically saying that there's a
disagreement on laws there's a
disagreement on how to run things so
people are deciding to hyperpolarize red
you know republicans move to red states
democrats to blue states and then
ultimately we're just going to decide to
you know just do our do our thing
yeah read about the civil war that's
what was happening southern states were
saying that the northern states were in
violation of federal law because they
were supposed to be returning slaves and
they weren't and if that was the case
why would they have to abide by federal
law if the north wasn't doing it if
california right now is not enforcing
immigration law
why then should you know texas enforce
federal abortion standards this is what
precipitates the breaking apart of the
union like we saw in 1860
then you had seven states secede before
abraham lincoln was inaugurated and then
after
there was a few more states i think that
joined in i think it was seven states
then when the battle of fort sumter
happened a bunch of other states went
whoa
like yo count me out like this is crazy
the union is going in now and their
states are supposed to be sovereign
robert reich is saying
you know there's an abortion issue is
happening so democrats are going to move
to blue areas and republicans to red
areas and i'm like yeah that's literally
what's happening
so when you have roe v wade and then you
get republican states basically saying
like we're not doing it anymore we're
gonna start you know and they get sued
over it
it's the lawsuits that brought us to the
point where roe v rowan casey may now be
overturned
but then the the democrats are gonna be
like republicans aren't abiding by by
the the laws of this land and it's like
dude california new york allowing
non-citizens to vote you kidding me it's
not just one one thing happening in one
area it is
democrats in the entirety of california
according to i can't remember which ngo
it was earned one extra electoral
college vote and congressional seat by
allowing illegal immigrants into the
state without enforcement because uh
congressional seats are apportioned
based on population size not citizenry
right all of this stuff it's it looks
very eerily reminiscent to what happened
in 1860. and you know how much it cost a
week president
maybe donald trump gets in and
you know what it costs every californian
every year to for illegal immigrants in
the states 1800
median for every single household in the
state i mean it's getting to a point
where the people that are fed up and the
left will continue to do whatever they
want they don't care about the standards
of federal law or what they're supposed
to do and then as soon as a conservative
republican president or republican
governor comes out and does something
like this then it's the end of the world
for them i mean that's conservatives
have to play hardball i mean i'm the
biggest fan of desantis because what
he's doing because he doesn't care at
all what the left thinks about him he
doesn't care about the political
standards that we're supposed to live by
he uses the power that he has and he
gets things done in a way that no other
republican governor has really done in
recent memory have you seen the left
they'll say like republicans are
steamrolling democrats because they're
too weak have you seen that rhetoric
it's amazing
so
to the left if they don't get everything
they want republicans are steamrolling
them to the right if they only concede a
little bit they're doing all right yeah
that's the amazing thing republicans are
like well we're going to give the
democrats what they want you got mitch
mcconnell they're not talking about red
flag laws no and i'm just like yo
there's no there is no right in this
country there there there's none i love
the la i'm i'm being somewhat facetious
the left says there is no left in this
country every single politician is far
right oh okay name the politician who
just stood up and said in the wake of
what we've just seen in this country
it's time to repeal the nfa it is time
to repeal all gun laws as infringements
and violations of the constitution not
nothing sorry it doesn't happen you got
a handful of republicans who talk about
it
where some people i think have proposed
bills but the republican party is not
going out saying repeal gun laws
the democrats are saying ban guns
i'm not saying that every democrat is
saying ban all guns i'm saying they have
quite literally banned a ton of them
they now want to ban assault weapons
which is meaningless where is that where
the republican party to come out stand
up and yell we have to unban selective
fire rifles
no because there is no right there is a
slow down there democrats and then
democrats that's what we have the speed
limit as conservatives have just left
leftists driving the speed limit yeah
that's essentially what it is every time
you give the left an inch they take a
mile the only reason why we are in this
situation is because conservatives
historically have been so weak to not
let anything happen and this is kind of
my gripe with libertarianism that kind
of got me in trouble on the michaela
peterson podcast when i talked about
this which i'll say again because i
think anyway libertarianism in in
essence is you know it's the kind of
liberal
uh
answer of saying you know if it happens
in someone else's home then it's fine
whatever happens outside there it's okay
that's kind of the libertarian answer i
don't want other people to get involved
in my life and as soon as you have that
again pitted up against the ideology of
leftism that is revolutionary in its
essence then you get a society that
continually gets steamrolled by these
types of people so if you have these
like classical liberal types i don't
know exactly where you guys are but you
have these classical liberal types that
say live and let live the left will
steamroll you every time because you
continue to give up things to them yes
the party that just wants to be left
alone will always lose always wants to
win where's what we're seeing this is
what i'd love to say to my undercut
friends i don't care if they're the left
anarchists don't believe right-wing
anarchists exist
and i think it's really funny denying
their existence they do they do they're
like you can't be a capitalist and an
anarchist it's like you can you know but
sure whatever but i like to just say
where's the great anarchist civilization
sorry there isn't one i mean there was
like a brief period in catalonia where
there was like an arctic state or
whatever you've got some parts of mexico
today but the reality is that without a
centralized authority you get
steamrolled by authoritarians who
exploit your your
for the most part peaceful nature
this is what it really bugs me too about
conservatives anarchists are not violent
and i say this to all of these people on
the political compass memes subreddits
and things like that they're like
libertarian left and they show antifa
and i'm like dude
you can't be libertarian and violently
beat someone with a bike lock into
submission so they do what you want
politically that is authoritarian you
are like adhere to the authority or i
will beat you that is not libertarian
left libertarian are like hippies on a
farm sharing their watermelon right
libertarians are the farm you know one
town over that's selling the fertilizer
to the hippies in exchange for
watermelon
but people don't understand that they
think left libertarian in the political
spectrum is like woke people no no no no
woke is authoritarian left yes we will
destroy your life unless you adhere to
our ideology
you do not see left libertarians all
that often you just don't
i'm thinking about like the people
sitting still maybe the libertarians
people that don't want to be bothered by
the outside world they'll be surrounded
rooted out and destroyed usually by a
stronger state force so the romans the
way they figured out was we're just
going to kill and subjugate our
neighbors so that no one can come and
take us but that's the imbalance that's
like the authoritarian imbalance at some
point it's state versus state whether
that's your house and his house
you both have your doors locked you
maybe you know each other maybe you
share keys but i doubt it and like so
where do you go where do you fall in the
balance of state power
i'm i'm actually more of uh i think the
state could actually do more in some
ways and less than others i mean i i
think there's a lot i actually we took a
trip even i am one of the first times
that we ever saw each other we went to
budapest and i gave a speech there and i
think that a lot of the things that
hungary is doing is actually quite
successful where they understand the
power that they have to make people's
lives better and they emphasize the
family and people are doing pretty well
in hungary i mean they're having great
economic recovery and the family unit i
mean the child tax credits you're
getting hungry like if you have up to
four kids you can get a free car from
the cup free cardio you get a car from
the government in some ways a liberal
democracy is not a dirty word there
right exactly it's illegal in liberal
yeah so that's the left today is
illiberal
right but what they mean by that is the
idea that you can have a democratic
society which i mean hungary is
but still not embrace liberal values you
know i'll tell you this communism
it works
i'm gonna wait so that people get pissed
off and then i'm gonna yeah i'll go for
it it works
it works in two circumstances theory an
extremely small population like a family
itself where the dad is in charge and
gives everyone what they need to do
their thing but we wouldn't really call
that communism that's not communism it's
a commune right but it also works when
you have an ideologically homogeneous
culture
you get a thousand people that all
blindly follow each other and agree with
their their cult ideology and you will
have
this functioning society the problem is
communists always try to enact that and
there's only one way to do it kill
everyone who disagrees which is why in
reality communism never works because
there are too many different ideas too
many different people they'll never
agree with each other unless you have
some weird small cult yeah what does the
left think democracy is the left thinks
democracy is when it's only their
opinion right everyone else's opinion
gets shut down the evil there's a
difference i'm not sure if you've read
the book jonathan hyde his book on uh
what's it called i can't remember the
book but essentially he does studies on
on the difference between
uh the righteous mind yeah right i think
so yeah where people who disagree yeah
yeah and so conservatives their outlook
on the world believe that people are
naturally born not good and that we have
to overcome our bad natures to do good
things in society whereas leftists think
that okay people are actually born good
but there's a small group of evil people
that we have to take out so that we can
have this good society that's why you
hear conservatives call leftist
brainwash where left is called
conservatives evil most of the time and
so that difference yeah now now the
right is calling the left evil yeah
which is gosh
so yeah we should start yeah right a
little bit exactly like that difference
whenever i point out periodically we'll
say like hey you know we invite leftists
on the show all the time they don't come
only a couple have ever come
i've done that and then i get these
prominent leftists we're like i'll come
on your show and i'm like awesome we
will pay your travel we'll get you the
fanciest hotel you get a limo whatever
you want then they privately messaged me
saying i'm not going to your show it's
all performant if it was all they wanted
they want a hoot and holler in front of
their followers like i'll do it and then
behind the scenes say oh you know i
can't sorry it won't happen. so i point
out
whenever i say this
what happens is the prominent left
personalities refuse to do it no or
they'll try and play this dirty game
where they'll be like i'd absolutely
love my appearance fee is fifteen
thousand dollars some nonsense no like
trying to do things knowing that we
would not ever do it so they can say we
cancelled on them or something but then
we get lower uh like people with like a
smaller body of work or less followers
and they'll be like i'll do it
and here's what here's what you realize
when you okay well we're going to try
and be fair and have these people on
they have no idea what they're talking
about no you ask them to elaborate the
ideas they have no idea they'll say what
i don't understand huh what do you mean
and they'll just keep repeating slogans
the higher profile leftists
i believe for the most part they know
why not to engage with people who are in
the liberty side of things because it's
not all conservatives like you're you're
mentioning classical liberals i'm not i
don't i i've always considered myself
social liberal which is basically the
mirror image that's well centrist
libertarian position sure
but we you know we have a bunch of
people on the show all the time we
disagree like sheamus is pro-life i'm i
would say more so pro-choice i hate
saying pro-choice because
the left is just
gone so crazy with it but we disagree
all the time
the more prominent leftists know they
can't actually come on the show because
they will be obliterated because their
ideas have no merit for the most part i
agree with some of left-wing you know i
ideas and stuff and i can argue that i
can agree with some of the criticisms
about you know unfettered markets and
things like that but when it comes to
facts
is joe biden corrupt
yes
it is a fact that he went to ukraine and
threatened to withhold us aid in
exchange for the firing of a prosecutor
who happened to have been investigating
a company where his son worked i'm not
saying that's why he did it but
any politician going to a foreign leader
and saying i will unilaterally suspend a
u.s debt obligation to you
that's corruption
they they accuse trump of doing that now
if you bring on one of these left
personalities they'll deny they'll say
that never happened no never happened
yeah i bring these people on we show
them the video and they're just like
what what about the steele dossier
yeah what about hillary clinton's role
in approving these things they don't
read the news it's tough because
eisenhower warned us about the liberal
economic order the military industrial
complex and was like yo they we just
built like a world police just so you
know and watch out because it's going to
try and take over the country and it did
within like two years but it's like
culture shock people didn't know that
until about 12 years ago when the
internet appeared now we can study like
you know the federal reserve and the
military liberal economic order and so
they're like having cognitive dissonance
and when you if you really want to shake
someone off out of this like i don't
know if you call it leftism or what but
this liber this liberal
or the idea of just believing whatever
the establishment says i guess yeah i
feel like that's more how i go about
things now is divide people within the
the people who know and people who don't
know so to say because you're not i feel
like there's no way that you're going to
wake someone up to the fact that there
are no 73 genders you know like if you
still believe that now or if that is
your your world i'm i'm not gonna try
and convince you that there are only two
sexes i i'm just i'm over that you know
that's done and i feel like most
conservatives should be more or less
done with that now i tweeted
simply neo pronouns are made up
because they literally are hey what is a
neo pronoun like z zemser oh um but
there i don't even know what that is
they're literally made up and i don't
mean that in a disparaging way it's like
people sit down and then try and come up
with pronouns yeah so i just tweeted
neopronouns are made up because no one
disagrees and boy they got so angry at
me i'm open in the word neo new so it
must be they were just like everything's
made of tricks idiot you
no but that's what they think that's
what they think they think that
everything is a social construct so of
course that's what they're going to say
to you words are made up right and and
words get meaning all the time
but it is not in dispute among the left
or the right that neoprones are made up
right that's why i thought it was funny
to state something that was just like
that statement of fact and they got mad
about it they think the way you're
saying it is disparaging in a way that's
also just you yeah well this is the
funny thing i once
hassan [ __ ] once made a joke so i
screen grabbed and just repost it cause
i thought the interaction was funny and
then he responded as though i didn't
understand his joke like the the the
the assumption is always adversarial
it's because your twitter picture you
look mad if you were happy and laughing
in your twitter picture people would
think that things were typing were happy
you know what i should do i respond to
people like these leftist personalities
all the time
either to agree with them on certain
issues and like not approach them in an
adversarial way but their followers do
not like it i think it's hilarious i
mean like twitter it's worth yeah the
worst you get way more negative replies
on twitter than positive replies most of
the time what's text in general there's
no context yeah most people in their own
bubbles will get their own bubble yeah
but i'll see like vosh tweet something
and if he says something and i'll if i
say if he says something i agree with
about guns or whatever then i'll respond
affirmatively and his followers are just
like now you can't agree that's not
allowed yeah it's like everyone ever
dude
let me let me pull up this story from
cnn business so we can have the last
segment just be fun from cnn walmart
apologizes for selling juneteenth ice
cream
so they tried to make awoke ice cream
and the woke attacked them for it
why are we worried about these people
what does it taste like yeah uh what are
they what do they say they say um
great value
my favorite that's why they got see see
this is why they got mad oh the branding
no no it's because everyone knows great
value is like the bargain bin
so
that's certainly why they're like hey
whoa we're not bargain bin we want ben
and jerry's that's right when they do it
it's cool yeah no juneteenth at arowan
market so what did they say they said it
was a red velvet flavored ice cream okay
what is red velvet isn't that just like
red vanilla basically right chocolate
it's just like a lot of red dyeing a
vinyl cake or something yeah cream
cheese on it wait but shouldn't it be
like chocolate ice cream i thought oh is
it chocolate juneteenth yeah right
chocolate is that right velvet i don't
know i don't know there's one critic
there's melanin in this case one critic
on twitter that's highlighted why it's
important to have diverse voices at the
table when making strategic business
decisions when you don't you end up
making costly foolish mistakes dude
this is the most tepid
and like
normal thing you can do to celebrate
juneteenth a holiday any holiday right
they made a holiday themed ice cream
they do it all the time we have a
maracone dream with stephen colbert and
it's you know it's great
yeah
and so
i think what we actually see here is
that no matter what you do when you try
to pander to these people you'll never
win
yeah you're just you're just wasting
your time it's kind of like when your
enemies make a mistake don't stop them
but at the same time if your enemy's
making a mistake and the mistake is
destroying your environment then maybe
you need to stop them we got it we got a
fact check adrian curry said red velvet
is chocolate
really yeah okay so then it is works for
june teen yeah but it's red
[Laughter]
definitely dudes maybe that's why they
got mad i guess yeah
i don't know
buttermilk eggs hey who had an issue
with this oh this says vanilla and cocoa
so i guess we're all right oh it's gross
well they shouldn't have put vanilla in
it oh yeah buttery
the goal they canceled it that's crazy
who cares
they apologize they apolo walmart and
wait so they're not yelling we gotta
rush out and buy something yeah if
anyone has some send it to the show i
mean i i would love to try some
juneteenth yeah i still have the old
aunt jemima
with the old ben or the ben uh gold
uncle ben's rice i have that from we did
a cancel culture on my show i think you
had a whole thing i think it's funny how
the woke people are only getting mad
about the black people on on branding
it's like mr clean's fine this is
butterworth it's not even black and they
got rid of that did you guys ever read
bomb pops it's red white bomb pops it's
red white and blue that sounds racist no
it's a red white and blue uh uh what do
you call it like
that sounds very american though it's
not crazy
yeah they call it sponsored by the obama
bomb pops dude i used to eat this when i
was little it's red white and blue and
they called it it's like a bomb like how
militaristic is our society
we used to eat these look it's just like
bro we had we
like they were teaching me as a kid drop
bombs yeah it's american of you
the ice cream the ice cream truck would
pull up and you know you'd get a bomb
pop and it was like explosively awesome
what was it even made of
cherry lime and blue raspberry no it's
water water and sugar coal tar water and
sugar the ingredients are water sugar
corn syrup and high fructose corn syrup
i just i just love that it's red white
and blue and it's a bomb you know it's
so ridiculous that's great it's a dutch
dog gaddafi approved isn't
yeah yeah french i think actually oh
okay well we can we can fight over it
french dutch french function i just
think like
you have this red white and blue for
americans it's obviously america right
it's a bomb
that should be offensive to americans
because it's like how dare you put bomb
in america together as if to imply we
think it's hilarious i think it's
awesome i think it's funny and it's like
yeah america does bomb a lot of kids
yeah so selling it but like then the
juneteenth things happen these people
get mad about everything like if
somebody if somebody you know
you see it with ben shapiro all the time
they'll make fun of him and he laughs
and he rolls with it he's like i don't
care dude it's funny you know i see
people post memes about me and i think
it's funny these people just want to be
angry all the time because their life
meaning if you have no meaning in your
life then of course you want to be angry
i tried to listen to angry people i was
like you know what i feel like
communication can overcome whatever we
need to so i'm like i'll give it a
chance and you listen to them and like
okay they're feeling better and then
they start and then i get insulted by
them and i'm like i can only handle so
much i don't have so much time in the
day i don't want to waste 12 of my next
like at some point receiving the abuse
is no longer
tolerable
yeah we had to build a rage room in the
house it's this uh it's this small
padded room yeah because ian will get on
twitter and they start shaking and we're
like quick get him to the room and then
we put him in he's like i broke it
ava's gonna need one of those after
living with me for a little bit there is
no
twitter needed no children
no i mean i deal with these angry people
i mean i've i've done plenty of events
speaking events where i'll have people i
did one at university of northern
colorado and they told me i had to wear
a mask while i spoke and i said you know
no not wearing a mask while i speak and
i take the mask off as soon as i get up
on stage and these about 50 black lives
matter thugs come they're flipping the
tables they're giving death threats to
the people who are there they're taking
their mask off telling me to put my mask
on i and they're just threatening
children i mean it's really terrible
it's angry angry people i am curious
what their main complaint was with this
juneteenth thing because i would think
that this would be great but they're all
like oh you didn't have enough diversity
yeah no they're like oh no we're winning
the culture war and walmart's supporting
our ideology quick we can't claim
victimhood
get rid of it really basically oh the
revolution eats its own it does it
absolutely i just looked at the
netherlands flag is it really that
trippy is it the one where it looks like
you're looking into like a burst of
color like red white and blue all flying
past you that's it's just red white blue
oh stripes stripes i got that one but
then i got this
what are you getting
so there's the amsterdam flag which is
different than the dutch floor there we
go okay yeah that's that's the punch
because the french is red white than
blue so if the bomb hop was sideways it
would be france okay so if it's flying
this way it's if it's sitting right it's
it's dutch it's not the russian flag
because the russian flag is white blue
red that's right
so it's funny i've
since ava moved into my place i put a
big dutch flag up in my place but i was
talking to her like people don't know
flags very well and i have a person who
comes and watches my dog when i go out
of town and i'm worried that he's gonna
think i have this huge russian flag
in my place talking about ukraine and
everything you know i went and got
yogurt we were out on a weekend and we
all went to like a game store and got
yogurt and there's like a chalkboard
there and it was just like chalk for
anyone to draw and people drew ukrainian
flags and it was like right around the
start of all this stuff and i was just
like this is the stupidest thing ever
you have no idea what you're supporting
no none no
it's on the transplant now right or the
yeah yeah
what where where
what's the source for that i could not
find i could just i don't know i've been
seeing it everywhere i think i think
people were making that up probably it
could definitely be real so
i wouldn't put it past them the pride
flag has the trans triangle with the
black and brown in it and then the
rainbow to represent
folks i think they call it and now
there's one going around with yellow and
blue for ukraine but i've not seen any
official leftists like account or
organization use that yeah okay i'm
looking forward to getting away from
rectangular flags and starting new new
shapes three-dimensional flags yeah
stuff like that it's like wait is it a
square or rectangle it's a square run
attack it's a cube it's a cube attack
yeah you're right it's a cube
is it a rhombus
that means you attack they probably just
have rectangular flags because they flow
better in the wind maybe they're easier
to mass produce
yeah i'm getting kind of tired of it
it's kind of boring to look at the next
revolution that's the liberal the left
we're going to do big tv screens instead
of flags in the future yeah it's like
why use a flag just put up a big deal
they have plans
so you knew if you were safe yeah yeah
but then like you're off in the middle
of nowhere and you see a flag of your
country you know you can go there and
you're saying the enemy could fly your
flag well that's why they call folks
they wouldn't because then right but if
they did they would get attacked by
their people mm-hmm
so you had to be careful about it plus
it's really you know what's always weird
to me as like rules of war where it's
like if i have a white flag i'm going to
respect that i'm like why why would
anyone do that
you know but back in the day it's like
you flew a white flag all right come on
in let's talk yeah i guess because you
want war to end so you need to have some
understanding but that was still a lot
of foul play in wars back then oh yeah
for sure no yeah
back then back then yeah
i mean this war in ukraine is just
totally honorable and great you know no
problems whatsoever accurate media
coverage vietnam had some accurate media
coverage that was the last time they
realized we're not going to put
reporters in the war anymore we're going
to give you a cookie cookie-cutter look
at what's happening like the first iraq
war apparently had a friend in the war
they were like yo we would laugh at the
media coverage of the tanks rolling down
the desert but like we were kicking in
doors and mowing down families it was
just horrific
the war propaganda for ukraine is just
it's it's it to me it's laughable you go
on reddit
and it's just like here's a ukrainian
soldier giving a warning to russians and
it's like some the camera's at a low
angle pointed up in a guy and you got a
cigar he's like listen you russia what's
hanging like ukrainian and he's like and
he flicks the cigar and he's like we're
coming for you and then all the comments
are like yes love ukrainian and i'm like
come on dude
it's just all propaganda and they're
like i loved when they reported about
mario paul getting conquered by russia
and they're like cessation of
hostilities it's like what does that
mean the fighting stopped and why
because russia won it's like okay that's
what we're trying to get to right yeah
how do you guys think of yourself like
on the balance of white pill and black
pill if you do a percentage scale
maybe a little bit so again as a
christian myself baptized christian
about year and a half ago i mean i'm
definitely in
i understand that all the things that
are happening now are indicative of what
human nature is i mean when you read
scripture and understand i mean these
things are kind of called out in a lot
of ways of how people are going to act
within the world it's it's basically
foretold so many of the things i'm i'm
not one to say revelations or anything
right now that's not what i'm saying but
many of the ways that humans are acting
right now is basically how humans are
going to act you will you will sin you
will go against your creator all these
kind of things and so i see that as very
natural
and so it's kind of white pilling to
know that if you have the truth on your
side then even if 99 of the culture is
against you you know what is true and
that's white pilling to me but then it's
also black pilling in the sense like
culture really sucks and there's a lot
of things that are going really terribly
right now no i've gone down to rabbit
hole a fair amount especially during the
covet days you know the vaccine mandates
and everything it came real close in
europe mandatory vaccinations in austria
it was really like it was a matter of a
month or so and then suddenly they
dropped it and for me now to get to be
here in the u.s the only reason i'm here
right now is because i was able to
travel on an exemption ground
otherwise it wouldn't have been it you
can't you can't enter the u.s unless
you're vaccinated yes that's exactly it
wow yeah the other way around same thing
so unvaccinated citizens
u.s citizens can go to europe and
unvaccinated european citizens can go to
the u.s so i was only right now right
now and nobody talks about it people
don't know this how do you get it how do
you get an exemption
well i got a government letter because
i'm gonna i'm gonna do some humanitarian
work so the humanitarian exemption is
one of them but there are very few so
and i'm a lawyer so i got this
opportunity because i have the knowledge
to do so but other people you know i get
messages from people every day
who haven't seen their their family and
their friends in years because of these
regulations because of these
restrictions so and those are you know
those are evil
what about medical exemptions
the medical exemptions are very very
rare very rare yeah yeah they won't give
them out to you
yeah a lot of doctors did all this stuff
no well not for the travel for between i
thought the travel stuff ended no yeah
no one knows this no one i mean for me
to come to amsterdam all to see her i
mean the the regulations in place the
things that we had to go through was
just insane now between america and
europe it's it definitely didn't end and
in europe within europe a lot of it
ended but they're gonna
they're on you know they're still
working on the european digital identity
i don't know if you guys ever talk about
any of that not enough well you've not i
wouldn't i would love to talk to you
about it yeah
yeah so go deeper on the after show into
that if we don't what in a nutshell what
is it oh yeah well the european digital
identity project is a project by the
european commission which is basically
to make a basically a passport a digital
passport for every single person in
europe so every single european citizen
will have a digital app
that well basically the the digital
covet pass was the first stage of so
everyone in europe had a digital vax
pass i feel like a lot of americans
don't know that that was used to give
you access to like everyday things so to
go to restaurants for example you would
need to get your app scanned
to get into the restaurant so you know
vax pass is the ones that you have the
paper ones that you can you know
you couldn't in europe so you were just
excluded from society if you didn't have
this pass
there are many countries in europe that
have lifted entry requirements for
vaccination yes so
the question is once you get into the
schengen zone are you then able to go to
yeah
yeah okay so you can't fly into the
netherlands no but you can fly into
poland and then travel from there to the
netherlands no because poland is also in
the shang zone so so no you won't be
able to says poland uh well i just
pulled up schengen visa info says poland
has dropped entry requirements for
travelers for americans
it says uh
well i it just says that it also depends
on the risk of the country
restriction free entry to all travelers
well maybe they've done that now for a
couple of countries then that's good you
can see austria hasn't the netherlands
is not in there so belgium has it that's
not yeah so then with it if you are in
europe then you could go but for at
least for my country for example because
this is this is what i heard someone was
telling me that they had to fly to like
poland and then take a train okay
because they wouldn't allow you to come
in by a plane well that's that's
relatively new then
because there was an eu travel ban in
force for basically the entire continent
i think this is probably the result of
the fact that they've dropped a lot of
restrictions also for europeans yeah
look at this look at this sorry to
interrupt you in the netherlands it says
travelers from third countries are still
subject to the entry rules but not if
you're coming from the eu schengen area
yeah that
well but i mean you still would have to
get for example now vaccinated travelers
who go from europe to america also still
need to get tested
so well well hold on there we all know
the southern border has no uh security
so honestly i think it would have been
easier for me to go from this from
mexico into the u.s than to get this
exemption ground that i now have to go
in a legal way but i'm a lawyer i need
to go in a legal way you know and this
is all
i can do all these things so that's
great but for other people who don't
have
the option
you know that's just it's heartbreaking
and it's it's all arbitrary it's evil
but yeah the digital the digital
identity thing that is really something
you guys should look into because it's
really really scary and that's all
that's a much bigger thing that's not
just going to include your vac status
but it's going to include biometrical
data it's going to include your taxes
it's going to include potentially even
you know central bank digital currencies
if it comes to that so the european
union is
incredibly focused on the digitalization
of your everyday life so basically your
entire life will become an airport
experience where you have to check in
and check out if it's up to these people
i was very shocked when i came to europe
and experienced that for the first time
it's so scary it's really scary i feel
like you guys should be really thankful
that it's not as far yet here yeah well
it's getting there you know we have guns
yeah right but this is this is i think
we've talked about this a lot during the
cove times you know when we had the
lockdowns and and in europe
in the netherlands it was crazy we had
curves we had the lockdowns obviously we
had the vax passes which basically track
you everywhere you go so the government
knows everything about you
whether you can go to restaurants or not
all these things were all dependent on
whether you had this digital pass and
obviously they put they are digital
they're qr codes so they're protected
against fraud so you you know you're
really screwed if you don't have them
was there a corporation that built those
or was it the government that built them
very familiar it was a government that
built them and there was a european
system as well so they had the european
uh digital covet pass which was exactly
what it what they mentioned in the in
the reports was sort of the beginning
phase of this digital wallet that
they're going to use for every single
european citizen for much more than just
just your vac status so we got to we're
going to go super chats i want to give a
shout out to denmark man you've probably
been there a lot right i actually that's
the one country i haven't been to i've
never i've never been to denmark it's
been in norway i've been yeah i've been
to norway i've been to sweden i've never
been to denmark but i would love to go
i'm just you know i'm reading these
countries i saw denmark was on the list
of like you can freely travel there and
i've it's it's weird i've been to
copenhagen so many times and christiana
have you ever have you ever traveled
there negative the free city of
christianity oh i've heard of that yeah
they like declared independence from
europe
and they're just kind of like no one
pays taxes or something it's crazy
amazing so you can communicate works it
says now leaving the eu i mean this
business isn't there when got a hot dog
yeah it was cool this is a great burger
place in copenhagen i loved going there
that was fun have you been to amsterdam
uh yes i have okay yeah
a lot of bikes a lot of bikes yeah yes
yeah yeah i was only there for like a
couple days though did you take
mushrooms no i went do you think you
will next time no i don't think so
i went to a conference and talked about
the news
and then everybody was riding bikes
everywhere it was funny yeah it's like
the bikes have like more rights than
cars yeah first time my first time i
rode a bike in amsterdam
yeah i crashed on the bike
what happened first time well i thought
it would be like an american mountain
bike and i get on this bike this
amsterdam dutch bike
and i thought i was going to really
impress ava oh no
and i ran into a range rover humbling
yeah very humbling which i needed so it
was good all right let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash the like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends take that url post it everywhere
you can now watch the show actually at
timcast.com it will automatically be
posting to the front page little
flashing light live we're going to be
doing a bunch of other cool stuff with
infrastructure and
companies that are resistant to
censorship that's gonna be a lot of fun
we're gonna have a members only show
coming up for you at 11 p.m don't miss
it sign up at timcast.com let's read
all right adaro the wholesome says tim
you said go buy a billboard well i can't
i can't afford a physical one and i
think ian would argue that this is a
digital one tim take my money check out
adora the wholesome on twitch because i
felt like it spin the ufo already i'm
spinning it now and i do agree with you
billboard's digital billboard let me let
me ask you mr witt how much do you think
a billboard costs on average well that
that's spinning you should ask ava i
actually know the answer to this
question oh i think because prageru is
actually trying to draw now
okay
i'm going to say something stupid no
you'll be fine like you like you see a
billboard on the side of the highway or
like on the side of a building like how
much you think it would cost in america
yeah
gee
i i had no idea i literally have no idea
is it gonna be crazy expensive super
cheap crazy cheap yeah so you can you
can get um
for like 400 bucks a times square
billboard
for you know half a day or something i
mean you guys did the taylor yeah yeah
yeah yeah with the daily wire guys and
uh it's it's you know i don't want to
get involved in the daily wires of
business stuff so i'm not going to say
too much but we uh you know we're going
to be doing a bunch of ads and we're
going to be let me just put it this way
we're going to be asserting ourselves in
culturally dominant spaces
billboards cheat they're the you can get
like everyone should do this then on the
conservative side yes
bombardier
right well yeah but think about um
so it can get expensive if you're buying
a lot right i think if you want to get
your ad to appear in every subway of new
york and on every bus it's like three
hundred thousand dollars wow for how
long a month wow
now three thousand dollars a lot of
money
but think about what that is
every subway every bus doing a a run of
ads everywhere like a couple hundred
grand that's kind of crazy think about
how much it costs to advertise on a
major network just on one of the prime
times a week it's insane twelve thousand
dollars yeah i mean that listen
people who run businesses like even a
small business if you have like maybe a
couple restaurants you're going to be
making maybe a million bucks it doesn't
mean that you have a million bucks in
cash and you're a millionaire it means
your company generates the revenue it is
it is not out of the question for for
any one of these conservative businesses
to do these things especially the daily
wire guys they have a time square
billboard for harry's
they could afford to basically take over
a city yeah in terms of just every major
highway saying you know you know it's
it's also about what's effective so for
us we're looking at ways that we can
culture jam as as marketing
so we want to do things that are going
to
you know we just we just you know i
don't want to say anything yet because
in a few days we're going to be doing
something so i won't reveal it but i
just want to make sure all the blue
checky journalists are frustrated every
single day and you know so
yeah yeah so anyway
so in times square for instance
there if you go on these digital sellers
these websites where they do automatic
sales it's like four dollars per play of
a video on one of the biggest billboards
four dollars so it's like okay spend 40
bucks and boom you're there for you know
it'll get you like two hours worth your
video will play in in a rotation if you
spend 400 bucks you're gonna be there
all day
people don't people don't know that i
mean not everybody has 400 bucks to
spend on something like that
but yeah i mean that's not out of the
question for the average person if you
wanted something ridiculous right
all right let's see we got
alex lindquist says just got out of a
three-year coma please explain uh aliens
took over uh rift in this time space
continuum witches came out cast spells
and you're healthy yeah
that's right
all right spirofluoropolis as i have
purchased sources say.online and begun
coding the word cue system should be
ready this week did you hear about my
idea
no well depending yeah you can't sue
wikipedia for defamation
because of section 230. you also can't
sue an individual editor because they've
made no statements
if you were to write on wikipedia ian
crossland
pet a dog
well that's not defamatory ian has pet
dogs probably in the past year or so
true yeah so you've said nothing wrong
wikipedia has had nothing wrong
then lydia goes in and changes pet to
eight
she did not accuse ian of eating a dog
all she did was say one word
who do i blame
who does he sue
he can't sue you and he can't sue her
because no one said anything that makes
no sense right so i said i mean i'm sure
my my argument is actually you can sue
wikipedia should be liable
but you've got to get the lawsuit so
precedent is set to to answer that
question so we have this idea for
something called sources say
someone gave us the name of it on the
super chat
when you when you when you load the
website you're placed in a queue
in the queue you're allowed to type one
word
so we'll make an article titled nancy
pelosi and then it'll say sources say
blank if you're the first person then
you get the first word second person you
get second word everybody gets about 15
seconds to put their word in and then
you watch the article write itself as
everyone adds just one word
who gets sued
i didn't write it it's user generated
not a single user made a statement they
all added one word so we can write whole
articles that basically say who knows
what because everyone's going to be
adding random words
and with the queue system you'll know
what's before you so you won't you know
someone could sabotage and write
nonsense but it won't fall victim to
like the the twitch plays errors where
it's all a bunch of random gibberish
twitch plays pokemon right you'll see
people it's all over the place and
they're trying to struggle to get it to
move with this you're you're sitting
there you have 10 seconds enter a word
read what you've got yeah it's going to
be fun maybe we'll have the time limit
increase as the paragraph gets bigger so
you know what word you're adding
so it looks like spiro is going to have
that done very nice
all right murph tri says congrats to
lydia on her first opinion piece for the
website can't wait to read more tim a
guest you should have on is dr lee
stillman he has a sub stack and just had
a great live stream on testosterone that
sounds interesting what was your first
opinion piece on lydia so i'm for my
first opinion piece i wrote about this
new study that came out that seemed to
indicate that people who have more than
two children have a higher risk of
developing dementia later in life and i
looked at some of the things that might
make that untrue at first i thought it
seemed a little bit like propaganda to
try to prevent people from having more
kids but then it turned out they studied
a bunch of european adults and they
don't they have much more of the state
intervention where people will go to a
nursing home instead of living with
their families for longer and i was like
that might actually be a sign of a deep
societal issue so i kind of looked into
that and it's up on the site and uh i'm
excited happy right for the site more
interesting yeah yeah
all right mark the mariner says will wit
you are behind enemy lines by thousands
of miles and will never see that goddess
land
oh i'm sorry never said that godless
land would i don't know if that what
they're trying to say
maybe talking about los angeles yeah
move to texas and convert our california
refugees to the lord
hell yeah brother so i heard uh i'm on
my way i was in austin recently and
apparently the austin liberals are
freaking out
like apparently they're telling people
like all these conservatives keep moving
here and like it's changing the
landscape of things what do we do good
good keep going
all the california conservatives should
move to move to those places
and and absolutely change it was sad we
were saying about l.a but i think before
the show you were talking about the
homeless escalation of the homeless
population on ventura boulevard
hollywood boulevard you see that video
of the guy who gets in a car accident
yeah we just want to yeah
the homeless guys then surround him and
start looting his car when he tries to
escape they drag him out of the car and
start beating him kick him in the head
wow really terrible and that stuff is
pretty commonplace going to be honest i
mean the crimes that happened on skid
row is yeah oh man one of my fondest
memories of uh california was in los
angeles and i was going to a shopping
center i was trying to get a bubble tea
and this big fat that's your first
problem yeah yeah
i love bubble tea thai tea and so this
big fat woman walks in the middle of the
street pulls her pants down takes him
off no and just
california just relieved herself
from the hot hot and i was like wow well
you get used to it america poop on the
street i mean later like i grew up in
colorado and you don't see it too much
there it's gotten worse in denver
colorado people know that but i mean now
it's just like oh you see a homeless
person you step over them that's just
commonplace i used to go down to
terrible i used to go to skid row back
when i lived in atlanta i'd hand out
water bottles and i'd bring the cameras
before iphones and i was like i wanna
right around that time i wanna record
these people get their testimonials and
then put it online so that people can
like help them but they never wanted to
people were like i don't wanna be a part
of it man well i went to skid row and i
actually interviewed homeless people i
did this for a documentary that i was
doing called fleeing california on
prageru i did that about two years ago
all about how california is failing in
places like texas are thriving and i
went and interviewed homeless people and
you talked to so many of these people i
talked to this one guy who's a father
and he said yeah i lived in louisiana i
had two kids and a wife but i decided to
move out to la to skid row to be
homeless
i'm like you you lived there in
louisiana you had kids i was like but
why he's like
easy life you know i can just come out
here they gave me a phone
wow i'm like okay they gave you a phone
and then you talk to these people who
actually work like in the government
offices with that the amount of
administrative i mean this is what
tocqueville talked about when you're
talking about the administrative state
and democracy in america that you have
this administrative state and most of
the money that is supposed to go towards
homelessness 12 billion last year in
california just goes towards
administration that's really useless
let's read some more we got andy
lighterman who says
watch the stream live on timcast.com you
can participate in the chat if you're
logged into youtube in the same browser
lydia looks lovely tonight oh thank you
that's not sage like wisdom
he's the guy behind putting the stream
on the site
the master behind all the technical
endeavors that we've done all these
trips we've done have been impossible
would have been without andy yeah it's
fun
yeah he's good
all right he's got a limber body being a
skater and all yeah eric max says tim
from the show yesterday there is an
atmosphere on mars enough for a drone to
fly and there is one uh and there is one
on there right now yes that i was
corrected on that one um we talked about
how there's a drone that they flew up in
the air that's crazy and i got a story
from september 2015 nasa confirms
evidence that liquid water flows on
today's mars
pretty powerful
all right i think it's under the surface
coridian says ava i have dutch ancestry
they changed the spelling of my last
name at some point in the 1700s it was
spelled h-u-n-g-e
but the u had a dot above it what does
it mean i heard it's common like smith
is there
say it again the name
h h u and g e
with a loud
oh with an umbrella okay well that's
actually very uncommon in the dutch
language i feel like that's german so
if you have an
uh
like that is how it would be with an
umlaut so in german you would have the u
would be an oo
and then with an umlaut on it would be
an u sound so
i actually interesting we hardly have
umlauts in the touchline what about the
single dot was it just a single dot they
said
is there anything like that of you with
one dot on top of that no okay no free
men die free says
hey tim you still owe us an episode with
ron paul
also the libertarian party's national
convention is this weekend have dave
smith and michael heiss on again after
lpmc can save the us if they succeed
sure that'd be great yeah dave's cool i
just texted dave earlier man i love that
guy he's so chill dan eines says the
nine most terrifying words in the
english language are quote i'm from the
government and i'm here to help ronald
reagan
you know i i do love that but i suppose
if like you know you were being invaded
and some dudes in army trucks pulled up
and said i'm from the us government
we're here to help you be like that's
cool thank god yeah right
like that's a good thing that's maybe
what you want government for it for yes
defending you there yeah culture
that's it
reineck says there are 100 000 public
schools in the united states if we take
this completely random amount of money
40 billion and divide it by 100 000 the
average salary for an armed security
guard is about 33k a year that's 12
guards per school it's not 33k
maybe maybe i'm wrong but i'm pretty
sure it's more than that
yeah i guess it depends on the state too
no
i don't know
east f says biden i did that stickers
are appearing on formula shelves in
louisiana oh no
spreading
wow that's bad
steven b says hey tim did you see that
amala beat you to the taylor silverman
interview
uh
everyone also beat us to the uh cal
rittenhouse interview yeah it's okay i
don't i don't like the idea of this rush
to like grab someone who who like
appears but you saw the taylor silverman
thing right mm-hmm so uh i've actually
spoken to her quite a bit and we've got
a plan uh i offered to cover the the
losses
for the so if those aren't familiar
taylor silverman's a skateboarder she
competed in a contest a biological male
1 first place ended up taking i think
like that 1 250 from her
i i did the math wrong but i said i
would cover the difference right which i
said 2250 because i didn't realize she
didn't win best trick but you know
whatever we'll cover that
so we're planning something i'm just not
a fan of this thing that happens in the
in the media where someone will do
something and then every single media
organization will be firing off emails
like you have to come on my show first
you can come to my show first
you know no i i don't i don't want to do
that people were like why won't you have
kyle rittenhouse come on and i'm like
already can come on whenever he wants
but i'm not going to do this thing like
right after his court trial we're going
to like email him and be like come on
our show not someone else yeah why the
rush
i just i just i don't i'm not the kind
of person who likes to run full speed
towards the finish line to compete with
everybody else we'll do it when it makes
sense it's more about the quality than
getting them on at the time i mean i
think yeah you want something that lasts
i mean you'll watch jordan you can watch
that jordan peterson interview i did
with gq
four years later and it's still great it
doesn't matter though it was
first yeah i want to have uh
you know when i when i got started
with uh political stuff like when i got
a bunch of attention during occupy wall
street it was happening to me everybody
was emailing me and calling saying come
on my show come on my show and then i
was just like nah this is flavor of the
week stuff it's like they want to get
you on to get some press i'm gonna do my
thing my own business you remember we
did an interview on prague a few years
ago oh yeah yeah yeah this is like yeah
do you actually remember it i think that
was just audio though wasn't it or it
wasn't was a camera uh it was like very
basic i think it was some camera stuff
on it yeah when i first started prageru
like four and a half years ago yeah
you're one of the first interviews that
i ever did i think i was pretty terrible
is it online is it up online right now
uh potentially yeah you can maybe i
don't know if no it's not online i don't
know it's probably pretty embarrassing
i'm sure if you went on facebook and you
looked up tim poole will win you could
probably find the interview yeah well as
a spring chicken yeah a little boy will
oh yeah i think i was very clean-shaven
oh nice you are no i am not yeah were
you 160 at the time i think 159 oh yeah
so i've put on some muscle synthetics
all right let's read some more we got uh
let's see
jean sebastian matt i'm probably not
saying that wrong tim two days ago you
guys were unsure about canadian prices
because unsure of conversions gas today
was two dollars two with 2059 dollars
per liter
times
3785 to convert for us gallons
times
0.78 to convert for the currency to usd
my prices here are then 5079 dollars per
gallon
maybe that's not correct
oh they use commas instead of periods
that's right yeah oh he's saying five
dollars per gallon yeah okay
oh okay that makes more sense you guys
are just commas right mm-hmm
that's wrong you're wrong okay well
we do
dates of birth differently than you do
yeah day of the month yeah yeah which
makes way more sense yeah sorry but yeah
no what month day monday or month year
you start yeah you start with a day then
the month then a year yeah 14
why does that make more sense yeah it
makes all the sense in the world small
longer longest yeah don't you also like
systems really don't you also put the
adjective after the noun
uh not in dutch not in dutch oh okay
that's a romance thing isn't it
uh i think well actually in the
well
depends a little bit yeah in french for
example certain most of the adjectives
go behind not all but most i kind of
feel like that makes more sense
you know it would be like dark cute yeah
because like you identify what it is and
then explain
the specific thing about it yeah that
makes sense the dog cute yeah yes
they talk all funny like you got to
learn to speak proper and such
all right where were we
ander webb says what will meant to say
was about the industrial
about the industrial revolution is that
it and its consequences have been a
disaster for the human race
yeah i think so yeah i mean i think
there's definitely some truth to that i
don't think
disaster is necessarily the right word
but i think there are implications that
people didn't
comprehend at the time that have been
hugely unsuccessful for humanity as a
whole yeah right especially with what
klaus schwab now calls the fourth
industrial revolution right
that guy sounds like a bond villain
right he looks like one too i know
what's up with that he was with the
pfizer ceo today talking at the the
forum that was talking about all the
conspiracy i watched that it was
hilarious
the the pfizer guy is like i saw a
picture of me in the fbi office and said
i've been arrested and i'm like how did
they get that photo yeah i thought it
was funny yeah
they made it dude what are you talking
about that was good
all right
that guy says tim there was little to no
mention of texas on last night's irl i
was curious as to what was behind the
decision not looking to criticize just
want to understand ian welcome back
weeknights aren't the same without you
bro the news had just broke the the news
hasn't had any have any uh we didn't
even have a complete number on the
victims and we had two tech guests on so
i was like i don't know how we like
have a conversation about texas with
these like tech guys these programs we
talked about it before the show kind of
decided against leading with it it
wasn't against talking about in general
it was just like
are we gonna have a robust conversation
that actually addresses the issues or
are we gonna mention it happened and
then be like we don't know enough about
what's currently going on like a lot of
the information hadn't come out till
this morning yeah i think that's
probably best i think you guys did the
good thing
well i mean it wasn't
it wasn't like a moral thing it was just
like i don't know what to say let's just
try and talk about what we can talk
about that's but that's also the right
thing because people will talk about
things without
knowing what to say right right it makes
things worse yeah
okay what do we have here there was one
i was looking at
that was pretty good where did it go
oh this one's cool kevin svenson crypto
says tim the military darpa and friends
are deep into developing neuro weapons
we're talking about direct ai to brain
communication no surgery dna resonance
frequency technology all remote this
will evacuate us all affect us all
eventually you guys ever see the movie
gamer no no the bad guy has like nanites
or something and then like if you smell
it he can control your brain
i think that's what the movie was i
don't know but did you there was
actually an army ad that got leaked by
data miners that was for for the us army
that was for new psychological warfare
techniques yeah did you see that i
didn't see it but i heard about it yeah
absolutely insane with this pensive
music and everything i mean very trippy
yeah talking plasma have you heard of
talking plasma they could they converge
lasers like three or more lasers into a
point in the sky and then it shows up on
radar and they move it around and make
people think they're seeing a ufo on
radar apparently they can make sound
project through this
through this coagulation or whatever you
want to call it this conflux and i
wonder if they can point to people's
brains and make them hear things like
diamonds are forever the world economic
forum released a video during the covet
pandemic where they said oh you know
face masks are now making facial
recognition very difficult
and yeah oh no and we but luckily nasa
has this technology laser technology
where we can identify you by your
heartbeat yeah and they present and you
know they had this type of elevator
music behind it as if it's such a good
thing and they just they posted that as
if it was you know i read uh an
article's normal thing in the world i i
don't know if you shared this lydia
there was an article that said that ai
can detect race based on x-rays yes
yeah everyone is mystified by the fact
and here's why it's a bad thing
right because it's like when a human
looks at a skeleton they don't know what
the a.i could determine with like was it
eight nine ninety percent accuracy
incredibly it's incredibly accurate i
remember hold on quick story i remember
there was a uh uh they uncovered a pair
of skeletons that were like clasped and
bryce and all the leftists are like it's
so beautiful there's no way of knowing
you know how old they were or what race
they were what they were and they're
actually like nah if you look at the
pelvis you can literally tell this is a
young man this is an older woman so not
only that they were like
they were like you can tell by the the
mandibular area yeah exactly they were
like it's an asian man and a white woman
yeah something like that they're like
you can literally determine all of that
based on these features that that's like
what actually gets biology is not
politically correct it is not
bad it's great
all right robert burroway says not sure
if you've all watched the show upload
yet but as a social commentary it seems
pretty spot on for the way things are
going i did watch upload have you guys
seen it watch no i don't know all right
it's it's a
it's a it's good
um
there are some things about it where
it's like yeah but they really get to
this futurism it's really interesting so
when you die they can before you die
they can upload you to a digital
afterlife and so basically you have a
guy who dies
and so at his funeral there's a gigantic
tv and he's standing
in the like he's he's in this virtual
reality where his consciousness exists
but it looks like he's just on the other
side of a window we just talked about
this when we started the show like as a
real thing
right
yeah what in reference how did we how
did that come up in the beginning when
we talked about you know the
the ai algorithms being so
advanced that they can potentially take
your thoughts and convert them into an
algorithm that you can continue to talk
to
for example if you're your loved one
dies would you put your brain in a
machine if you could no
no no no way yeah hell no would you
um
maybe like a birthday gift for her oh
yeah yeah i need an extra will
no it wouldn't be when i die i'd just
have like 10.
everywhere she goes here's what i want
you all to imagine right
i want you to imagine a gigantic
spherical blob monster that is black
with hands and feet coming out and like
moving out in faces going
they like come out of it and then you
see it lurking towards you and then all
of a sudden the face of your your your
dead grandfather emerges and in his
voice says join us
we are all happy here and then a giant
mouth opens up trying to that's what
that ai is going to be cloud schwab's
voice
it's like your loved one trying to
convince you i'm trying to convince you
it's fine and safe in here join us and
then you're like this is not real they
all float that's what right that's what
uploading your mind to the ai is going
to be it's going to be joining that
monster it's going to be walking up to
being like please i'd like to be one of
you no wait i wonder if you can upload
only like a copy in the but you still
are you that dies off then there's some
random copy out there yeah i think that
would be the idea
but if i mean the thing is that what's
so scary about this is people are going
to buy it you know like they're going to
be like oh this is a good thing because
they're going to sell it to us on our
nice pretext so they're going to say to
you like oh you know
wouldn't be wouldn't it be a lovely
world if we could you know eliminate
aggression
if we want peace on earth like we can
read everyone's minds and we can take
away the desire to kill
wouldn't that be great you know we can
eliminate murder we can have peace on
earth finally yeah it's called being the
borg yeah same with those like dna 23
and me things are like send us your
blood dna sample and we'll give you some
information you like
and with this it's like oh you don't
want that you don't want us to read your
mind you have something to hide yeah do
you want to make it up for
oh they do yeah oh yeah interesting
insanity all right let's read some more
we got joe doraki says tim for the love
of god will you shout out pop culture
crisis more lids was on today's show and
it was a great one yes ladies and
gentlemen pop culture crisis is live
monday through friday at 3 p.m right
that's correct yeah i got the time right
yeah and the days yeah
little secret treat for you guys i'll
tell you in here now i'm going to be on
the show tomorrow
3 p.m gave it away eastern standard and
we're gonna we're we're building that
infrastructure stuff so that we can uh
we're gonna be doing a marketing push
for pop culture crisis it's all in due
time
maybe even starting next week but um
we're doing a bunch of marketing stuff
that we've never done before and i'm
mostly trying to figure out culture
jamming as marketing because who cares
about buying like a commercial people
are like why don't you buy a commercial
on tucker carlson tim or whatever and
i'm like yeah we could or i can you know
think different i don't know throw a pie
or something yeah i mean yeah right next
to the my pillow advertisements i mean i
had a really good idea for a my pillow
thing so we made the hour pillow do you
guys know about that yeah i saw that the
it was the burlap sack full of packing
peanuts yeah and i wanted to buy a
commercial on fox news advertising it i
talked to fox they said yes
we just needed a producer who could make
the commercial and this is where we like
we i didn't have the managerial power to
execute but here's what i wanted to do
a commercial
where we have this like post-soviet
factory talking about how communist
pillow is a better pillow because it's
it's hard and makes you strong not not
weak you know those comfortable pillows
they make you soft you know you need
hardship in life hard times make strong
men yeah and then after that commercial
ends what i really want is for the
mypillow commercial to start in the
exact same location and it's mike
lindell with a bunch of my pillow
factory workers raiding the communist
factory and him telling you
not to buy the communist pillow and
there's like they're pillow fighting i
thought that would have been the best
thing ever this pillow makes you soft
yes good pillow my pillow makes you vic
you must buy strong communist pillow and
then mike lindell's like hold on there
mister my pillow is the best pillow
you'll ever have and then they they
storm in and kick the door in yeah that
would be the best thing ever
i bet mike would be down for that that
would be the cool thing so it would be
like a minute long and you're watching
foxy like what did i just watch this
can you get a thing in there about
dominion voting system it'll be good
i don't think he's gonna go anywhere
near that camera like spins around i'm
like the matrix as he's like jumping
all right we'll grab a couple more real
quick
how do you say that tous nalorum
nolarum says this is the first point in
history with extensive enough spying to
reconstruct an ancestor simulation with
the level of detail we have in day to
day life what are the odds of that if
simulation is possible chances are we
are in one
crazy
yeah i don't agree yeah i don't i don't
think that just because something is
possible that means it's probable but
you were just asking what chance is it
uh less than one percent i don't know
here we go
what does it say neil niriter says you
are wrong month day year makes more
sense saying the 20th has no meaning
without knowing the month it's just like
your noun adjective choice because the
duck is cute
so imagine it's imagine it's
it's february
and you say
you know
day
what do you say day month year
you know how are you going to know
if it's february or not right that's
that's that's it yeah eva but you're
you're all seeing them anyway
right so you're gonna say there's no
real one the fifth of february no i
agree with this super chatter i think
he's right no we don't say we say
february
will just want to disagree yeah i know i
know but we say the fifth of february
reading an extra word that's so
inefficient
right
okay she's like all right listen i'm
just from here okay from from there this
is how we do it jazz i'm a conservative
i don't like change okay says would you
kindly a simple phrase a man chooses a
slave obeys oh speaking of that my
friends if you haven't alread already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share this
show with your friends and head over to
timecast.com to become a member we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
at about 11 p.m you don't want to miss
it you can follow the show at tim cast
irl you can follow me everywhere
instagram twitter whatever at tim cast
will do you want to shout anything out
yeah you guys can go to prague.com to
check out any of our videos any of the
documentaries i've done any of the five
minute videos if you're into any other
stuff with dennis prager and his wisdom
make sure you check out his fireside
chats i'm on social media at the wilway
and you can get my book how to win
friends and influence enemies anywhere
books are sold
ava
right um well we just talked a little
bit about the digital identity and
that's a lot of that's basically what i
write about most i have a blog called
resist much obey little on substance so
everyone who's interested in the
digitalization fourth industrial
revolution
transhumanism and well mostly what
happens in europe with all of these
things because like i said it's much
more advanced and during cove but it was
also much more advanced than here then
please go check it out because you need
to know what's happening there if you
want to know what's going to happen here
i think a lot of the the resistance is a
meditation in a clear mind with no
thoughts they're going to try and read
your mind they're going to try and be
reading thoughts so if you can control
yourself to have none
that'll be a good resistance technique
in the meantime done let's have it i
want to shout out the minds festival of
ideas it's going to be june 25th in new
york city at the beacon theater and uh
we're going to be speaking there tim and
i are both going to be speaking there uh
we'll have some special guests as well
there's a great lineup go to
festival.mines.
if you want to check out the lineup and
you can get your tickets now you'll be
leading up to the uh the event imagine
nawaz i think right magic noise james
o'keefe is going to be there i mean it's
zooby's going to be there the list goes
on it's hot check it out wow it sounds
like it's going to be the greatest event
ever yeah it's like woodstock all over
again yeah
i don't think it's gonna be like
woodstock thank you guys all for tuning
in this evening this is a very fun
conversation i feel now like we should
have more couples on you guys can follow
me on twitter and mines.com at
sourpatchlits and my realm of influence
grows i'm planting the second lydian
empire i now have articles on
timcast.com i have my sub stack and then
my all my various um sour patch lead
stop me pulls it all together for you
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for that members show thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you